SUBCOMMITTEE FOR WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERINGS GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PRCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. TODAY ALL
OF THE CURRENT MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ARE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTICAL FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURED IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WITH WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE. IS. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL OF
COURSE MAINTAINED OCCUR DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE. AND I DON'T
EXPECT ANYBODY TO BE
DISRUPTIVE. THEY MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
JEREMY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT ALL INTERESTED. SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD IN MY EXPERIENCE IS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE DONE A PHENOMENAL
JOB SO I DON'T EXPECT ANY
PROBLEMS. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A COP A QUORUM.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND YOUR
CARD. YOUR EXPIRY HERE CENTER
COME LONGER CENTER COME LONGER
HERE SENATOR NELSON SENATOR
NELSON HERE. WE ARE ALL PRESENT
SO WE WILL BEGIN THE ITEMS
PROPOSED FOR DISCUSSION
STARTING WITH PROPOSALS FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION THE FIRST
ISSUE IS ISSUE NUMBER FORTY
THREE THE AUGMENTATION AND
CONTINUATION OF RESOURCES FOR
THE LICENSED PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS FROM MEXICO PILOT
PROJECT AND I'D LIKE TO TURN
THE MIKE OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT.
AND ASK- I BELIEVE WELL LET ME
JUST LET M JUST CHECK AND SEE-
IF. FOR STARTING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR OR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD.
OKAY LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THE MEDICAL BOARD
SO- THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS
WILLIAM PASIFIKA. ARE YOU ON
THE LINE. YES I AM ON THE LINE.
VERY VERY GOOD THERE YOU ARE
AND SO YOU MAY PROCEED. OKAY
WELL- WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
OUTLINE WHAT THE ROLE OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD HAS BEEN IN THE
BACK OF THE CO PILOT PROJECT I
THINK THAT PROBABLY WOULD BE A
GOOD PLACE TO START. WELL
ACCORDING TO MY TIMELINE THIS
IS A PROJECT WHICH IS GOING ON
FOR SOME TIME. FIVE COURSE ONLY
ARRIVED IN THE SUMMER OF LAST
YEAR. BUT BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THAT IS IN FRONT OF
ME WE HAD THE FIRST MEETING- IN
RELATION TO THE MEXICO PILOT
PROJECT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN-
THAT'S WHEN WE FIRST BECAME
INVOLVED. WE RECEIVED THE FIRST
INSTALLMENT. OF OUR FUNDS IN
RELATION TO THE PROJECT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND THEREFORE
WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN THE
INTERVENING PERIOD IS THAT
THERE'VE BEEN A NUMBER OF
MILESTONES THAT HAVE BEEN
REACHED. IN TERMS OF BRINGING.
THE PROJECT TOGETHER. IT
INCLUDED- BOARD STAFF RECEIVING
A REPORT FROM A MEDICAL
CONSULTANT REGARDING THE
PROPOSED CURRICULUM FOR THE SIX
MONTH ORIENTATION WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WAS IN
APRIL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. IN
JULY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
BOARDAPPROVED THE CURRICULUM
FOR THE SIX MONTH ORIENTATION
OUR PROJECT- IN AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE RECEIVED TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND. FROM ONE OF THE
CLINICS TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROJECT.
I IN OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY WE
RECEIVED DICK EXECUTED
EXTERNSHIP AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
UCSF AND ONE OF THE CLINICS AND
THE OTHER CLINICS WERE RECEIVED
LATER IN THE YEAR. ADDITIONAL
INSTALLMENTS THE FUNDS WERE
RECEIVED IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. AND WHAT WE- BEAT THE
LAST CRITICAL PART OF
INFORMATION. WHICH WE RECEIVED.
ARM WAS THE SIGNING OF THE
INTER AGENCY AGREEMENT FROM UC
DAVIS TO CONDUCT THE EVALUATION
THAT WAS IN JANUARY OF TWENTY.
21% OF THAT TIME THE BOARD HAS
BEEN PREPARED TO ISSUE LICENSES
TO ALL OF THOSE APPLICANTS WHO
MEET THE CRITERIA AS OF TODAY I
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE TWENTY
ONE LICENSES THAT WE ARE
PREPARED TO ISSUE. AND WE ARE
NOT ISSUING THEM AT THE REQUEST
OF THE APPLICANTS BECAUSE THEY
OF COURSE NEED TO GET THEIR
VISAS THE R. LICENSES ARE GOOD
FOR A THREE YEAR PERIOD. AND
IT'S ANTICIPATED THAT THEY WILL
BE STARTING LATER IN THE SUMMER
SO AT THIS POINT ACCORDING TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD- ALL THE
FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENTS OF THE
PROGRAM ARE IN PLACE WE ARE
READY TO ISSUE LICENSES. AND
WILL DO SO AS SOON AS WE GET
THE GO AHEAD FROM THE
APPLICANTS. VERY GOOD- IT DOES
THAT CONCLUDE YOUR
PRESENTATION. YES I BUT I
pDIRECTOR ON THE TCA SIDE WITH
MAYBE LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
BUDGETARY POSITION. VERY GOOD
DEAD DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. AND THAT WOULD BE THE
FISCAL OFFICER TAYLOR CHECKED.
THAT'S CORRECT. MY NAME ISTAYLOR SICK UNDER THE SCHOOL
OFFICER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND- JUST TO
GIVE YOU A BRIEF OUTLINE HERE
WHAT THIS REQUEST IS
ESSENTIALLY DOING IS EXTENDING
FUNDING- COMMENSURATE WITH THE
TIMELINE FOR THE PROJECT RIGHT
NOW- FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS
THERE WAS A DCP THAT WAS
APPROVED. FOR THE INITIAL START
OF THIS PROGRAM BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY THE
LAST YEAR OF FUNDING FOR THIS
PROJECT IS ACTUALLY IN- THE
SCHOOL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO HOWEVER THAT FUNDING
LEVEL- ISN'T IN ALIGNMENT WITH
THE NEW TIMELINE AND WITH THE
CONTRACT WITHUC DAVIS SO WHAT
THIS REQUEST IS ESSENTIALLY
DOING IS PUTTING IN A REQUEST
IN PLACE TO ALLOW- PROVIDE THE
APPROPRIATION NECESSARY TO
FULLY COMPLETE THE PILOTS- OUT
THROUGH I BELIEVE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. BRIGADES OUT
SO THIS IS A REAL LINES THE
ACTUAL TIME LINE OF THE PROGRAM.
IS WHAT I UNDERSTAND. YES THIS
WILL THIS WILL REALIGN THE
FUNDING BANKS AND MEET THAT
TIME MORE INCIDENTS SINCE THE
TIMELINE SHIFTED A LITTLE BIT
THERE WERE THOSE VARIOUS
MILESTONES THAT THE- ARCTIC
HERE DIRECTOR OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD MENTIONED- THE TIMELINE
SHIFTED FROM WHERE WE THOUGHT
THE TIME LINE WAS WHEN THE
INITIAL PCP WAS SUBMITTED BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
SO THIS REQUEST IS JUST
REALIGNING THAT FUNDING-
COMMENSURATE WITH THAT
TIMELINE. AGAIN THIS FUNDING IS
FULLY SUPPORTED BY THE
NONPROFIT PHILANTHROPIC
DONATIONS FROM THE VARIOUS
ENTITIES THAT ARE SPONSORING
THE PROGRAM AND NONE OF THIS
WILL IMPACT THE MEDICAL BOARDS
ARE IN CONTENTION FOR VERY GOOD
THANK YOU A FINANCE. DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM.
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO FINANCE AN
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THANK YOU.
HOW ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. SORT OF BORED
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE DID NOT RAISE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
VERY GOOD I'M GONNA ASK IF- ANY
OF. THE SENATORS I HAVE A
QUESTION ON THIS IS THAT THIS
IS A BILL THAT WAS PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND INTO IT SO I'M
REALLY EXCITED AND HAPPY TO SEE
US HERE- WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THESE LICENSES TO BE ISSUED
BUT I WILL CHECK IN WITH THEM-
CENTER CAMEL OWNER THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIRWOMAN- YOU KNOW I HAD
ACTUALLY A QUESTION FOR- THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. FOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD BECAUSE I'VE ALSO
BEEN GETTING SOME INFORMATION
RELATED TO COST MANAGEMENT- AND
SO JUST WANTED TO KNOW IF HE
COULD MAYBE- WELL I THINK FOLKS
HAVE QUESTIONS AROUND SORT OF-
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY- COST
MANAGEMENT TOOK AROUND
EXPENDITURES- I KNOW THIS IS
UNRELATED BUT THERE AND-
PROPOSING A FEE INCREASE AND SO
AS WE'RE- LOOKING TO TAKE IN
MORE REVENUES FROM THE STATE I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR
FOLKS TO KNOW THAT THAT MONEY
IS BEING WELL MANAGED. SO YOUR
QUESTION IS ADDRESSED TO- THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. VERY GOOD%
MR PACIFICO IF YOU COULD JOIN
US AGAIN AND- SEE IF YOU
UNDERSTOOD THE QUESTION BUT SHE
WAS ASKING FOR YES ELL I MEAN
I GUESS THERE ARE TWO SEPARATE
ISSUES HERE ONE IS THE QUESTION
OF THE COST MANAGEMENT OF THE
MEXICO PILOT PROJECT AND IF
THERE ANY SPECIFIC ISSUES OR
QUERIES ABOUT HOW THOSE NUMBERS
WERE ARRIVED AT OUR TO THE
MANAGEMENT OF THOSE FUNDS OF
COURSE WE WOULD BE VERY HAPPY
TO ADDRESS THOSE SPECIFICALLY.
AND WE HAVE THE PEOPLE HERE WHO
ARE FAMILIAR WITH THE DETAILS
OF THE PROJECT IF THE QUESTION
IS ONE ABOUT COST MANAGEMENT IN
RELATION TO OUR FUND INCREASED
WHICH OF COURSE IS A MUCH
LARGER QUESTION I WOULD BE VERY
HAPPY TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
MYSELF I JUST ON THAT SECOND
POINT YES WE ARE LOOKING FOR
THE FEE INCREASE A FEE INCREASE
WE HAVE NOT HAD FOR MANY YEARS
I BELIEVE IT'S FOURTEEN YEARS
DURING THAT TIME A LOT OF OUR
COSTS HAD INCREASED. AND OF
COURSE 80% OF ALL OF OUR WORK
IN TERMS OF RESOURCES AND TIME
IS RELATED TO ENFORCEMENT SO
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN THE IN THE
BOUT THE YEAR THAT I HAVE BEEN
HERE IS THAT WE HAVE FOCUSED
OUR ENERGY ON TRYING TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
MANAGE OUR LARGE PROGRAM OF
CASE MANAGEMENT- WE ARE GETTING
IN ON THE ORDER OF ELEVEN
THOUSAND TWELVE THOUSAND
COMPLAINTS PER YEAR. SOME OF
THOSE CASES ARE EXTREMELY
SERIOUS AND REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS TO TRIAGE THE
CASES AND MANAGE THEM PROPERLY
SO THE ONES THAT ARE LESS
SERIOUS WE CAN DEAL WITH MUCH
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY DURING THE TENURE
THAT I HAVE BEEN IN JUST IN THE
PAST SIX MONTHS WE'VE REDUCED
THE TOTAL CASES UNDER
MANAGEMENT ACTIVE MANAGEMENT.
ON THE ORDER OF 13% WHICH IS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT A
LOT OF OUR ENFORCEMENT COSTS
ARE NOT UNDER OUR DIRECT
CONTROL. WE OUTSOURCED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND%
THE HEALTH QUALITY
INVESTIGATIVE UNIT. WHO MANAGE
THEM FOR US AND THAT'S REALLY
THE COST IS BASED ON TIME SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
BUILD UP OUR- CAPABILITIES
INTERNALLY. ARE MORE
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE CASES
DEAL WITH THE EASIER CASES
SIMPLY IN MORE EFFECTIVELY
WE'RE WE'RE SEEING THAT HAPPEN.
OUR NET FISCAL POSITION HAS
IMPROVED FROM WHERE IT WAS IN
JANUARY OF LAST YEAR. BUT IT
STILL REQUIRES THE NEED FOR A
FEE INCREASE BUT I CAN. ASSURE
EVERYONE HERE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ACTIVELY
MANAGE OUR RESOURCES WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME PRESERVING
RESOURCES FOR THOSE MOST
SERIOUS CASES AND I THINK OUR
NUMBERS DEMONSTRATE. THAT WE'RE
HEADING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
WE'RE NOT SIMPLY LOOKING FOR A
BLANK CHECK WE REALIZED THAT WE
HAVE TO MANAGE OUR RESOURCES.
VERY EFFECTIVELY AND WE BELIEVE
WITH THE REDUCTION OF TOTAL
CASES UNDER MANAGEMENT THAT
THAT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. NOW IF YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON THE
MEXICO PILOT PROJECT AND SOME
OF THE- OUR BUDGETARY MATTERS
THERE I WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE
THE QUESTION BUT THEN TO REFER
TO ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES. WHO IS
MORE FAMILIAR WITH THE DETAILS
OF THAT. PROJECT VERY GOOD. I'M
FINE THANK YOU FOR THAT
EXPLANATION THAT WAS WHAT I WAS
INTERESTED IN HEARING THANK YOU
HEY WE'LL TAKE IT THAT MUCH
SENATOR NELSON. NO QUESTIONS
FROM SENATOR NIELSEN- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THAT RECOMMENDATION STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO IMPROVE AS
REQUESTED WILL BE TAKING UP
THOSE VOTES AT A LATER TIME. SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE SO THANK YOU
I'M GOING TO MOVE ON TO. ITEM
NUMBER FORTY FOUR WHICH IS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
AND IT'S THE FIVE ISSUE FORTY
FOUR IS THE- C. A. DOT GOV
RESOURCES AND ASK THAT.
DEPARTMENT TO- PLEASE PRESENT.
YES HI AND GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS AMY TONG
ON THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AND ALSO
THE STATE CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER JOINING ME TODAY ARE TO
A COLLEAGUE OF MINE- BOTH ARE
NEW TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY ONE IS THAT THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR RUSS
MICHAEL CAME FROM- CDCR AND
ALSO OUR OUR NEW STATE
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION OFFICER A
GREAT CLOUD WHO CAME FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR BOTH JUST JOINED
OUR DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY-
MERRILY FOR COUPLE OF A FEW
MONTHS AGO- TODAY WILL BE
PRESENTING YOU TO PROPOSAL BY
SPEAKING WITH THE FIRST ONE
ISSUE FORTY FOUR. SPECIFICALLY
ON THE C. A. DOT GOV RESOURCES
BUT THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING- TO CONTINUE WITH
THE OPERATION OF MOVING THE
STATES- WEBSITES INTO A UNIFORM
PLATFORM AND SO THAT THEREFORE
TO PROVIDE TO A- UNIFIED
EXPERIENCE AS WELL AS TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION THE
SIMPLIFICATION AND
STANDARDISATION AND ADA
COMPLIANCE NEED TO FOR THE
WEBSITE TO ALLOW CALIFORNIANS
TO HAVE A MORE SEAMLESS
EXPERIENCE- WITH DATA I'M NOT
ONE TO SURE HANDED OFF TO RED
CLOUD TO ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THAT BACKGROUND OF THE
PROPOSAL AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. FROM THE
COMMITTEE. RICK THANK YOU AMY.
HI IT'S PLEASURE BEING- HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY. I THOUGHT I
WOULD PROVIDE. JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND ON WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT MOVING TO A
CENTRALIZED INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
THE CURRENT STATE OF. AFFAIRS
IS WITH US- THE WEBSITES THAT
ARE MAINTAINED ON CD
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THOSE THAT
AREN'T. ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY. WEBSITES ACROSS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT.
AND NOT QUITE SIXTY OF THOSE
ARE RUNNING ON THE CENTRALIZED
INFRASTRUCTURE MANAGED BY MY
TEAM AT C. T. AS WE LOOK TO
STANDARDIZE AND SIMPLIFY BOTH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ON WHICH
THOSE SITES ARE HOSTED. AND THE
OFFER CENTRALIZED SERVICES THAT
MAKE IT EASIER FOR DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES TO ENSURE
ACCESSIBILITY- INSURE THAT
THEY'RE USING MODERN TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY THAT ARE PATCHED
AND- AND SECUREWORKS- WE WANT
TO MAKE OUR TEAM AVAILABLE AND
MAKE THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF SITES
THAT HOST. INFRASTRUCTURE WE
MAINTAIN. AND PART OF THE GOAL
OF THIS P. C. P. IS TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE THE STAFF AND
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THAT- AS
WE LOOK AHEAD- WE EXPECT THAT
THERE WILL BE A GROWING.
DEMANDS DESIRE BY OTHER
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE US AND
LEVERAGE THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
CTE IS DOING WITH THE OFFICE OF
DIGITAL INNOVATION. TO INSURE
THAT WORD BEING AS RESIDENT
FOCUSED AS WE CAN BE- AND
ENSURE THAT THE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY ARE RESPONSIVE TO
THOSE NEEDS. ALL PAUSE THERE
BEFORE GOING ANY FURTHER THERE
ANY QUESTIONS. FROM THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT POST CODE. OR
WHAT WE INTEND TO ACCOMPLISH.
DON'T LET ME FINISH. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LA- AND THEN WE WILL SEE IF
THERE'S QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT PRESENTATION AND-
APPRECIATED VERY MUCH-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ANY
COMMENTS. BRIAN WANTED TO OPEN
A FINANCE OR SUPPORT OF THIS
FALLS SHORT OF NOTATIONAL
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S. PRIME
MINISTER LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE THE HEARING AGENDA
PROVIDES A SUMMARY OF OUR
ANALYSIS OF THIS PROPOSAL- WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THIS BUDGET REQUEST AS
PROPOSED AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- COMMENTS FROM SENATORS.
NO COMMENTS FROM SENATOR NELSON
I JUST HAVE- A QUESTION AND-
YOU KNOW OUR OUR TECHNOLOGY.
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OUT THAT
WAY AND IN MANY WAYS NEEDS ARE
A LOT OF- UPGRADING OR UPDATING
I GUESS IS THE BEST WAY TO PUT
IT AND- THIS IS A PROPOSAL TO
DO THE UPGRADING INTERNALLY
AND- AND IT'S A FAIRLY. A
MODEST AMOUNT OF MONEY GIVEN
TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS AND SO ON I
GUESS I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT WE'RE PUTTING THE
RESOURCES WE NEED AT AT A TIME
THAT REALLY APPROPRIATE AND-
THAT THE RESOURCES THAT YOU'RE
REQUESTING ARE SUFFICIENT TO
MEET. THE TIME LINE THAT YOU
HAD ANTICIPATED AND THE WORK
PRODUCT YOU'RE INTO SPECIES
COULD YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT PLEASE I MEAN I I'M
REALLY EXCITED THAT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THIS KIND OF
WORK. INTERNALLY BECAUSE WE CAN
CONTROL THE COST I THINK A
LITTLE BIT BETTER WE CAN BE
SURE THAT. THAT ACTUALLY WORKS-
BUT I WANT TO MAKE MAKE SURE
THAT- THE DIGIT THERE SOME
ASSURANCE THAT THIS IS GOING TO
GET US WHERE WE WANT TO GO. YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I'M
OUT I'M SURE AND I APPRECIATE
THE RECOGNITION DIED- THAT. ASK
IT'S MODEST BECAUSE WE'RE ALSO
VERY MINDFUL THAT- THIS YOU
KNOW. IT'S AN ADDITIONAL ASKED.
AS IN BACK IN THE- EARLIER BY
JAZZ WE DID ASK FOR A- LARGER
AMOUNT FOR- THE SYSTEM'S STAR
CRITICAL SYSTEMS THAT REQUIRE
STABLE A STATION. AND THIS AND
THIS IS IN ADDITION TO THAT TO
HELP MORE. ON FROM THE FRONT OF
ENHANCING. USER EXPERIENCE WHEN
IT COMES TO A CALIFORNIA
WEBSITES AND PARTICULARLY
DEPARTMENTAL WEBSITES. AND I
THINK WE WANTED TO BE VERY
CAUTIOUS AND BE A GOOD SCHOOL
STORE OF THE FUNDING THAT IS
BEING INVESTED IN TECHNOLOGY.
AND TWO VERY MUCH TOO HOW YOU
STATED WE ARE VERY PROUD OF THE
FACT THAT WE CAN DO THIS WITH
THE INTERNAL. STATE RESOURCES
AND TAKING A VERY MEASURED.
INCREMENTAL STEPS TO ACHIEVE
THIS- I'LL LEAVE IT TO. REST
NICHOLS OR RICK IF THEY LIKE TO
ADDED IN TERM OF OUR
MEASUREMENT OF SUCCESS. AND
HOW- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS A MODEST.
REQUEST WE CAN KEEP A VERY
HEALTHY PACE. AND CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE THE EXPERIENCE OF
WEBSITE- FOR STATE ENTITIES.
IRAQ OUR REST FEEL FREE TO JUMP
IN. I THINK COMING FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR I CAN SAY THAT
THIS IS ONE AREA WHERE- I THINK
WE'RE PLAYING FROM A POSITION
OF STRENGTH I WAS. PLEASANTLY
SURPRISED TO SEE THEIR TEAM HAD
ALREADY MADE A COMMITMENT TO
BEST OF BREED PLATFORM FOR BOTH
THE STORAGE OPERATION. AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE WEBSITES
THAT WE ARE MANAGING- WITH NCT.
SO I THINK THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT IN PRIOR- EFFORTS I
DO THINK THAT TO- DIRECTOR
THOMAS COMMENTS WE ARE WELL
POSITIONED WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
WHAT'S BEING ASKED-
SPECIFICALLY ON BRINGING
ADDITIONAL SITES ON BOARD. I
THINK IT IS POSSIBLE THAT AS AN
EXTENSION OF THIS AS WE BRING
MORE SITES TO SEE DOT GOV- IN
GENERAL THAT THE MORE THAT WE
HAVE THE MORE POTENTIAL THERE
IS FOR MORE LEVERAGE WHICH.
COULD BE FURTHER INVESTMENT
DOWN THE ROAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT AND- I
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU CAME FROM THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SO YOU HAVE SOME
PRIVATE SECTOR EXPERIENCE AND-
AND THAT'S ALWAYS A GOOD THING
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR FIELD SO
APPRECIATE. APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION THAT WE MAY NEED TO
SPEND MORE MONEY IN THIS AREA
BUT IT WOULD BE TO BRING ON
MORE RESOURCES AND- THE- BOOK
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE MORE
THAT PEOPLE CAN FIND OUT
INFORMATION. ABOUT MY DATA NOW
AND THEY WANT INFORMATION AND
IT'S FRUSTRATING WHEN THEY
CAN'T FIND. WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR SO- IF THIS HELPS
TO STREAMLINE THAT I. A. I'M
ALL FOR IT AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THIS IS A-
APPROVED AS REQUESTED AND SO WE
WILL BE TAKING ACTION LATER ON
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING AND
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR TESTIMONY
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING FOR BEING HERE TODAY FOR
HIM TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY FIVE. WHICH IS THE D. A
DIGITAL IDENTIFICATION AND I
GUESS AGAIN ASKED ON- DIRECTOR.
OF STATE CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER TOM GETS TO PRESENT ON
THIS ITEM. YES THANK YOU
ADVENTURE CONTINUING ON WITH
THE ITEM FORTY FIVE I JOINING
ME ALSO IS- RESUME COASTED UP
DIRECTOR AS LONG AS RICK CLASS
WAS GOING TO BE LEADING THIS
EFFORT I'M JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
A BACKDROP AS I CAN TELL FROM
THE STAFF REPORT AND- COMMENTS
pTHOSE ITEMS THAT THERE'S THAT
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF OPEN
QUESTION.AND IT ACTUALLY THIS
IS THE VERY MUCH ANTICIPATED
FROM THE FACT THAT I DO- WE ARE
SEEING THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY OPPOSED-
CALLED IT THERE'S MORE MORE
RELIANCE ON- USING THE DIGITAL
MEANS AS AS A WAY TO OFFER
PUBLIC SERVICE- BUT RECOGNIZING
DIED. BECAUSE OF THAT IF NOT
DONE CORRECTLY IT ALSO CREATES
A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR FRAUD
AND YOU KNOW FOR IN A SECURITY
YOU KNOW CONCERNS AND THIS AND
THAT AND THEREFORE- EVEN THOUGH
IT'S A QUICK TURNAROUND TO PUT
THIS PROPOSAL I WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THE FACT THAT WE ARE
BRINGING THE IDEA OF CREATING A
SINGLE DIGITAL ID. AS A WAY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LOG IN I WOULD
JUST AS A FRIEND OR TWO TO GET
ACCESS TO THE VARIOUS SERVICES
WERE BRINGING THIS IDEA S. AND
A PLANNING EFFORT TO THE
COMMITTEE TO THE LEGISLATURE
FOR US SUPPORT FOR THE VERY
VERY BEGINNING. WHICH IS ONE OF
THE REASON WHY THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT IS FAIRLY MODEST-
BECAUSE WE JUST WANTED TO YOU
KNOW KICKED US OUT FOR OFF WITH
A VERY OPEN AND TRANSPARENT AND
ENGAGEMENT OPPORTUNITY- TO WITH
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT
NEED TO BE ENGAGED TO START
THIS FROM THE VERY VERY
BEGINNING. ON UNLIKE SOME OF
THE PREVIOUS- PROPOSAL THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE SEEN IN FRONT OF YOU
THEY TYPICALLY CALM YOU KNOW
CAME TO YOU ALREADY WITH A
LARGER AMOUNT IN PROBABLY A
WELL WRITTEN- PROPOSAL- WHAT WE
FEEL THE DIGIT- ID WORK IS SO.
AND SO IMPORTANT DO WHATEVER
TAKING INTO. OF AS A PART.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE BRINGING IN
VERY INITIAL CONCEPT AND DOING
IT OPENLY- WITH A SMALL
INVESTMENT OR MODEST INVESTMENT
ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS- OVER A
TWO YEAR PERIOD. SO WE CAN
START WHAT IS CALLED A PROOF OF
CONCEPT. PLANNING THROUGH THAT
EFFORT AND THEN PICK ONE OR TWO
DEPARTMENT AS A PILOT
DEPARTMENTS TO TEST OUT THIS
THEORY AND THIS APPROACH.
BEFORE WE ARE POTENTIALLY COME
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IF THIS
IS PROVING OUT TO BE
BENEFICIAL. TO SKATE OUT BEFORE
ANYTHING FURTHER CAN BE-
CONSIDER- YOU KNOW A PRODUCTION
READY- SO I JUST WANTED TO PUT
THIS UP FRONT- AS A REALLY THE
INTENT BEHIND THIS PROPOSAL. IS
NOT THAT WE ALREADY READY TO GO
AND BUILD SOMETHING BUT IT'S
REALLY TO START AS A PLANNING
EFFORT IN ENGAGING THE
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THIS
ENTIRE PROCESS- BUT WITH THAT
CAP BY RUSS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADD. MORE INFORMATION ON THIS.
AND THAT WORLD READY FOR
QUESTIONS. LAST CORRECT MA'AM
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RUSTIC GOALS I
THE LEAST CIO AND THE CHIEF
DEPUTY COURT APARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY. AND AS A NIECE OF
THE PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU IS
VERY MODEST ISSUE POSITIONS OR
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
OVER TWO YEARS. AS WE'VE ALL
SEEN IN THE LAST YEAR WITH THE
PANDEMIC THERE IS A GREATER AND
GREATER NEED FOR THE DIGITECH
DIGITIZATION OF STATE SERVICES
WE HAVE OVER THREE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT STATE SYSTEMS THAT
PROVIDE DIGITAL SERVICES TO OUR
RESIDENTS. RIGHT NOW EACH OF
THOSE SYSTEMS IS MANAGED
INDEPENDENTLY AND THAT USER
IDENTIFICATION AUTHENTICATION
PIECE IS MANAGED AT EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF THOSE SITES
SOMETIMES SEPARATE SITES WITHIN
OUR DEPARTMENT. BUT EACH SYSTEM
DAN HAS TO MANAGE THAT
INFORMATION SECURE THAT
INFORMATION AND PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF OUR RESIDENTS. WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING REALLY IS A
PILOT TO CENTRALIZE THAT FRONT
END SERVICE WHERE WE IDENTIFIED
THE PERSON THIS COMING YEAR.
AND PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
THAT MANAGEMENT CENTRALLY TO
REDUCE THE SECURITY EXPOSURE
ACTUALLY INCREASED THE PRICE OF
PRIVACY FOR OUR RESIDENTS IN
ADDITION TO IMPROVING THE USER
EXPERIENCE FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE CONSUMING OIL SERVICE.
RIGHT NOW IF SOMEONE WANTS TO
CHANGE A PIECE OF INFORMATION
THEY HAVE TO REMEMBER EACH AND
EVERY SITE. IN WHICH THEY'VE
CREATED AN ACCOUNT AND GO BACK
IN AND MODIFY THAT INFORMATION
WHETHER IT'S A PHONE NUMBER OR
ANYTHING ELSE. YOU HAVE A GREAT.
THE GREAT SCOTT SCRIBE TO. SO
WE'RE PROPOSING IS A TWO AFTER
WHERE WE PLAN AND DOES AND
IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY. NECESSARY
TO AUTHENTICATE FOLKS TO MANAGE
THAT PROCESS AND ALLOW THAT
SERVICE FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
IT'S SCALABLE DEPENDING ON THE
SERVICES THEY NEED SO THERE ARE
SYSTEMS THAT REQUIRE A VERY
DEEP LEVEL. OF AUTHENTICATION
TO GUARANTEE THAT A PERSON IS
WHO THEY SAY THEY ARE FOR
EXAMPLE ANYTHING WHERE THEY ARE
ASKING FOR BENEFITS
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE MIGHT BE
AN EASY EXAMPLE. THERE ARE
OTHER SYSTEMS THAT DON'T
REQUIRE NEARLY THAT LEVEL OF
AUTHENTICATION. AND WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IS A IS THE ABILITY
TO RIGHT SIZE THAT SORT OF WORK
ASKING THE APPROPRIATE
INFORMATION FROM OUR RESIDENTS.
AND WHAT'S WE PROVING THEIR
IDENTITY THAT INFORMATION IS
ONLY AVAILABLE TO THEM AND IN
FACT. WE WILL. DESTROY THE
IDENTIFICATION INFORMATION IS
NO LONGER NECESSARY. FOR US FOR
TO BE MAINTAINED AND ASK FOR
THEM TO HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
ACCOUNTS. SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WHAT WE PLAN TO DO IS A PROOF
OF CONCEPT THAN A PILOT WITH
TWO DEPARTMENTS AT THE END OF
THAT PILOT WOULD BRING BACK AN
EVALUATION OF THAT PROCESS. AND
A RECOMMENDATION ON HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD IN A SUBSEQUENT REQUEST
BEFORE WE MOVE ANY FARTHER INTO
DEPLOYMENT ACROSS THE STATE SO
IT IS. A VERY IN DEPTH PLANNING
PROCESS WHERE WE ABSOLUTELY
PLAN TO BRING IN STAKEHOLDERS
TO GATHER REQUIREMENTS GATHER
THE CONCERNS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED. AND REPORT THOSE
BACK. WITH THAT WE'RE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON THIS VERY THOROUGH
EXPLANATION AND I APPRECIATE
THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. BUT
IN ONE OF THE FINANCE WILL
SUPPORT OF THIS CALL YOU'LL END
OF THE PLANNING EFFORTS TO.
LOOK INTO A BEGIN PUTTING
TOGETHER A PILOT PROJECT FOR
DIGITAL ID HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS OFFICE. BRIAN METZGER
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE OF
THE HEARING AGENDA AGAIN
PROVIDES A SUMMARY OF OUR
ANALYSIS OF THIS PROPOSAL- WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THIS BUDGET REQUEST AS
PROPOSED. AGAIN WITHOUT%
PREJUDICE TO THE POLICY MERITS
OF THE PROPOSAL WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THE BENEFITS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT FORWARD-
ONE POINT OF CLARIFICATION FROM
OUR ANALYSIS. CDC HAS APPROVED
THE STAGE ONE BUSINESS ANALYSIS
FOR THIS PROPOSED PROJECTS BUT
IS REVIEWING THAT APPROVAL
DOCUMENT APPROVED DOCUMENT
ALONGSIDE A POTENTIAL
DELEGATION REQUEST FOR THE
PROJECT. SO WE HAVE NOT
RECEIVED THAT DOCUMENTATION AND
OUR CONCLUSION- REMAINS OF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE THE
INFORMATION NEEDS TO FULLY
EVALUATE THE PROPOSAL SO HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SENATOR NELSON YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS-
TO START OFF WHAT IS THE WHAT
WHAT CRITERIA ARE YOU USING TO
DETERMINE WHICH DEPARTMENTS
WOULD BE PART OF THIS PILOT
PRO. JECT THE INITIAL PHASE OF
THIS PLANNING EFFORT IS TO
DETERMINE EXACTLY THAT IN OTHER
WORDS WE'VE NOT REFINED THE
EXACT CRITERIA HOWEVER BECAUSE
IT IS EIGHTY EIGHT PILOTING A
PROOF OF CONCEPT. WE WILL NOT
BE USING SYSTEMS THAT CONTAIN.
A CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
STRUCTURE WHERE HEALTHCARE
INFORMATION OR ANYTHING
EXTREMELY CONFIDENTIAL WHEN WE
GET TO THE PILOT WE WANT
REPRESENTATIVE SYSTEMS THAT CAN
SHOW THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE DIFFERENCES
ARE THAT THEY REFLECT IN
CULTURAL DYNAMICS FOR. LANGUAGE
OR THINGS ALONG THOSE LINES TO
ENSURE THAT AN AUTHENTICATION
SYSTEM COMMUNICATES WELL WITH
THEM BUT WE ARE NOT PLANNING TO
TAKE ON HIGH RISK EFFORTS IN
THIS PILOTS WILL BE. RELATIVELY
BENIGN SET OF APPLICATIONS
THANK YOU FOR THAT I APPRECIATE
IT BECAUSE THAT WAS PART OF
THAT WAS. PART OF CONCERNS THAT
WE RAISED- THAT WE HAD THAT I
HAD IS THAT- THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES OR HEALTH THE
HEALTH CARE DEPARTMENT CONTAINS
A LOT OF- SENSITIVE INFORMATION
AND- AT MOVIES STAKEHOLDER
OUTREACH IS PROBABLY GONNA BE
PRETTY IMPORTANT- COMES UP FOR
THE DEPLOYMENT OF- ANY OF THIS
KIND OF TECHNOLOGY. AND THEN
THE OTHER THE OTHER CONCERNS
AND THAT RAISES THE ISSUE OF
WHAT NON GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES.
IS IT ANTICIPATED THIS THIS
INFORMATION WOULD BE SHARED
WITH- AT EIGHT OH. NON
GOVERNMENTAL OR OUR
GOVERNMENTAL PARTNERS- AGAIN
BECAUSE OF SENSITIVE
INFORMATION AND- HOW WOULD YOU
MITIGATE POTENTIAL SECURITY
BREACHES AS PART OF THAT. PART
OF THE PLAN. FROM THERE- LET ME
ADDRESS THAT I THINK THEY'RE
ACTUALLY TWO UNDERLYING
QUESTIONS THERE. THE SECOND ONE
ON THE MANAGING THE EXPOSURE TO
SECURITY BREACHES BY
CENTRALIZING THIS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGICAL
CAPABILITY MANAGING OR
MONITORING THIS MUCH MORE
ACTIVELY. RIGHT NOW WITH THOSE
CREDENTIALS STORED IN THREE
HUNDRED SYSTEMS ACROSS THE
STATE IF ONE OF THOSE SYSTEMS
IS BREACHED TO COMPARING LIKELY
THOSE SAME CREDENTIALS COULD BE
USED ACROSS OTHER SYSTEMS. THE
ABILITY TO MONITOR THE MONITOR
GOES ACROSS ALL OF THE VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS RIGHT NOW ALL
DEPENDS ON A LOT OF INTERACTION
AND COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS. CENTRALIZING IT
ACTUALLY RAISES THE BAR ON THAT
SECURITY THROUGH OUR SECURITY
OPERATIONS CENTER AT THE STATE
LEVEL WE WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO DETECT FOR EXAMPLE LOGGINS
COMING AT EIGHTY EIGHT CASE IT
IS NOT REASONABLE FOR A SINGLE
PERSON TO BE ATTEMPTING WALK
INS. OR FROM DISPARAGING
GRAPHICAL CATIONS. I CAN'T LOG
IN FROM SACRAMENTO AND THEN
TWENTY MINUTES LATER BE LOGGING
IN FROM. PHOENIX AND TWENTY
MINUTES AFTER THAT FROM THE C.
OR FROM ANOTHER CAR. WE THE
CABLE WITH THIS SYSTEM TO THOSE
THINGS AND MITIGATE MUCH MORE.
IF WE NEED TO CLOSE THE DOOR.
SO THAT THAT THE SYSTEM IS NO
LONGER ACCESSIBLE BY PASCAL- WE
CAN DO THAT IN ONE PLACE RATHER
THAN. RATHER THAN HAVING TO GO
OUT DOWN TO THREE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT AREAS. ON THE-
QUESTION OF INFORMATION SHARING
WE WOULD COLLECT COLLECT
INFORMATION TO APPROVE THE
ACCOUNTS BASED ON THE SYSTEMS
THAT FOLKS WANT ACCESS. AT THE
POINT THAT WE HAVE PROVEN THAT
IDENTITY. THEN SOME OF THE
INFORMATION WOULD ACTUALLY BE
DELETED WE DON'T NEED TO
MAINTAIN IT. ANYTHING THAT WE
DO MAINTAIN WOULD BE ENCRYPTED
AND WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO THE
RESIDENTS WHO SUBMITTED THAT
INFORMATION. AND WHAT ALL WOULD
NOT BE SHARED BY US PROACTIVELY
WAR UPON REQUEST BY ANY OTHER
ORGANIZATION. OR ENTITY WITHOUT
FOLLOWING APPROPRIATE FEDERAL
OR STATE LAW- AND SO IF THERE
IS A QUESTION FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT- THAT THAT
REQUEST WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH EXISTING PROCESSES AND
WE WOULD OF COURSE ABIDE BY ANY.
STATUTORY OR POLICY STANCE THAT
THE STATE HAS A COUPLE. VERY
GOOD APPRECIATE IF I MAY ADD TO
THAT ANSWER AT MANAGER JUST ONE
THING I WANTED TO ALSO LEVEL
STEPPED UP A CONTEXT WHERE THE
INFORMATION THAT IS BEING
COLLECTED THROUGH THE DIGITAL
ID- IT'S YOU KNOW FROM THE
DISCOVERY PROCESS IS NOT THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE ANYTHING
MORE THAN WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL
HUNDRED FIFTY PLUS DEPARTMENTS
POTENTIALLY ALREADY COLLECTING
THE CRATER USER ACCOUNT. THE
DIFFERENCES IS THAT INSTEAD OF
INDIVIDUAL HUNDRED FIFTY
DEPARTMENTS COLLECTING THEIR
INDIVIDUAL INFORMATION WE WILL
BE COLLECTING THE SAME AMOUNT
POSSIBLE EVEN LAST UP BUT IN A
MUCH MORE STANDARDIZED FORMAT
SO YOU DO IT ONCE AND THAT
INDIVIDUAL WILL HAVE TO LOG IN
TO THE VERY S. PUBLIC SERVICE
IF THEY WANT ACCESS TO SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
ALSO. CLEAR THAT IT'S NOT LIKE
THERE'S GOING TO CREATE A NEW
SETS OF INFORMATION THESE BEES
COLLECTED. THAT HASN'T ALREADY
BEEN COLLECTED. I PREFER I
PREFER THAT. I MEAN I THAT THAT
IS INDEED THERE'S NOTHING MORE
FRUSTRATING THAN HAVING TO GIVE
THE SAME INFORMATION OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR-
DIFFERENT PURPOSES BUT ALSO
ALWAYS. BE IF PEOPLE SEE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS ONE
ENTITY EVEN IF. YOU'RE
OPERATING OR YOUR- INTERACTING
WITH DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS- TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT. IN A WAY THAT
PROVIDES THE SAME INFORMATION
EVERYBODY WOULD BE I THINK VERY
BENEFICIAL AND- BRING US INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY IT'S
FOUND THE QUESTIONS ARE THE
ISSUE OF SECURITY- EXACTLY WHAT
THE DATA IT WILL BE USED FOR
WHETHER. IT'S POSSIBLE TO MY-
WHETHER THERE'S ANY INTEREST IN
MONETIZING AND I WOULD THINK
THE ANSWER TO THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT- BUT THOSE ARE
THE KIND OF QUESTIONS I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO ASK AND TO MAKE
SURE. MAKE SURE IN THIS REALLY
I DO UNDERSTAND THIS IS A PILOT
PROJECT YOU'RE NOT BUILDING THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM YOU'RE TRYING TO.
WORK ON. ON TRYING TO CREATE
THIS SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT WILL
WORK FOR ALL OF THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT YOU INTEND TO PUT TOGETHER
AND- I DO APPRECIATE THAT- THE
THOUGHT THAT'S GONE INTO THIS
AND KIND OF THE M. STEP BY STEP
THINKING THAT YOU USED IN IN
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER RATHER
THAN PROPOSING A HUGE PROJECT
AND- IT IS TO TAKE IT IN BITE
SIZED PIECES I REALLY
APPRECIATE- I THINK THERE'S
SOME SOME QUESTIONS AND MAYBE
SOME MORE DISCUSSIONS TO BE
HELD- HI. I THINK IT'S-
PROBABLY A GOOD IDEA TO DO IT
IT'S BACK PART OF THE PROJECT
BUT THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEMS
SO WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT OPEN
TODAY- AND I EXPECTED TO SEE IT
BACK IT AT SOME. FUTURE DATE
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IT'S BEEN VERY
VERY VERY HELPFUL THIS. THIS
AFTERNOON. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FORTY SIX
WHICH IS THE IN. THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT. THE
CONSOLIDATED HEADQUARTERS
COMPLEX. AND I WANT TO INVITE
THE- DEPARTMENT. TWO I GUESS
IT'S GOING TO BE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THAT IS- PRESENTING
THIS. HI MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
NUMBER SIX IS FAR. FINANCE GIVE
YOU A QUICK OVERVIEW ON THE
PROJECT AND WHERE IT CURRENTLY
STANDS IN THE PATH FORWARD AT
THE MOMENT SO MILITARIES
CONSOLIDATED- HI- HAD QUARTERS
COMPLEX PROJECT WAS FOUNDED IN
200-016-2000 SEVENTEEN. FOR
PERFORMANCE CRITERION DESIGN
BUILD FOR A TOTAL OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE MILLION THE PROJECT
WHICH IS ABOUT SEVENTY PER CENT
COMPLETE SITS ON THIRTY ACRES
AROUND FOR CORDOVA NEAR THE
MAJOR AIR FORCE BASE. YEP SORRY
NEAR THE MAY THIRD AIRPORT THE
PROPERTY WAS ACQUIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THE PROJECT
INCLUDES THE CONSTRUCTION OF
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
CONSOLIDATED HEADQUARTERS
FACILITY THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT ARMORY AND
A TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT STORAGE FACILITY. IN THE
COMPLEX WILL CONSOLIDATE APPROX
ME THOUSAND EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY
WORKING OUT OF NUMEROUSLY
SPACES THROUGHOUT THE
SACRAMENTO AREA. THE PROJECT
WHICH HAS BEEN UNDER
CONSTRUCTION SINCE LATE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EARLY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE RECENTLY
BECAME AWARE OF NUMEROUS
CHALLENGES WITH A PROJECT THAT
HAD BEEN GOING ON FOR SOME
TIME. THAT RESULTED IN
SIGNIFICANT CONSTRUCTION
DELAYS. CHALLENGES HAVE
INCLUDED COMMUNICATION
BREAKDOWN BETWEEN THE MILITARY
AND THE PROJECT'S STRAPPED IN
THE CONTRACTOR. INCONSISTENCIES
BETWEEN THE R. F. P. AND THE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT. IN
CONCERNS WITH INSPECTION
OVERSIGHT. MOST RECENTLY AS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA ON MARCH
NINETEENTH THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL ISSUED A STOP WORK
ORDER ON THE PROJECT. CITING
NUMEROUS IDENTIFIED
DEFICIENCIES THAT REMAIN AND
CORRECTED. SINCE THEN ALL WORK
ON THE PROJECT REMAINS
SUSPENDED. IN THE PAST FEW
WEEKS WE HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH MILITARY ON
HOW BEST TO GET THIS PROJECT BY
CONTRACT. WE HAVE COLLECTIVELY
AGREED THE BEST COURSE OF
ACTION IS TO ENGAGE THE
EXPERTISE OF DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES RATHER DIDN'T
CONTINUE. TO MANAGE THE PROJECT
WITH MILITARY PERSONNEL ONLY.
TGS IS ALREADY ASSIGNED A
PROJECT DIRECTOR TO THE PROJECT
ANDTHAT PROJECT DIRECTOR HAS
RECENTLY WALKED THE PROJECT
SITE IN ORDER TO ASSESS
CONSTRUCTION STATUS. IN
ADDITION DIGEST HAS PUT IN
PLACE. A CONTRACT FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION SUPERVISOR AND ARE
WORKING ON A THIRD PARTY
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT FIRM
CONTRACT TO RECONCILE THE
SCHEDULE AND REVIEW AND
EVALUATE OUTSTANDING CHANGE
ORDERS. TGS AND MILITARY ARE
MAKING EFFORTS TO RE ENGAGE
WITH THE CONTRACTOR BEGINNING
WITH A PARTNER IN MEETING THAT
IS SCHEDULED TO TAKE PLACE
TOMORROW WITH ALL PARTNERS.
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT THESE
EFFORTS WILL COOK QUICKLY GET
THIS PROJECT MOVING FORWARD
AGAIN AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR CLOSELY AS THEY-
PROGRESS MOVES FORWARD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WANT TO CHECK
AND SEE IF THE DEPARTMENT OF.
FINANCE HAS ANY. THAT WAS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MEC. HOW
ABOUT WE MOVE ON TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANNA'S ANALYST'S
OFFICE. SORT OF BORED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DID NOT RAISE CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL AND ARE HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE. VERY GOOD. SENATOR NELSON
ANY QUESTIONS. NO QUESTIONS
FROM. FIVE I APPRECIATE THE-
THE DIFFICULT SITUATION THAT
HAS BEEN CREATED BY THIS WE
NEED TO GET IT BACK ON TRACK NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT- THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS BEEN
MADE AND- THE PROJECT NEEDS TO
BE. COMPLETED THE STAFFRECOMMENDATION IS TO REJECT THE
GENERAL JANUARY PROPOSAL
PROVIDING POSITION AT THIRTY
FOR MAINTENANCE PERSONNEL A NEW
CONSOLIDATED HEADQUARTERS
COMPLEX AND APPROVE THE ONETIME
ARGUMENTATION OF ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION THAT REFLECTS THE
ELIMINATION OF THE SAVINGS- SO
WE'LL TAKE ANY ACTION- LATER
ON. ON THE AGENDA BUT I THINK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY APRECIATE- THE UPDATE ON
THE PROJECT AND THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE THINGS HAPPENING AS
WE SPEAK- I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT UPDATE I THINK I SHOULD
ALSO ADD THAT IT'S- LIKELY THAT
YOU CAN ANTICIPATE THAT THERE
WILL BE SOMETHING IN THE MAIL
REVISION I WAS JUST GONNA SAY
THATIS THAT IT- I EXPECT THAT
THIS IS NOT THE LAST THAT WE'LL
SEE EVENT- IN WHICH CASE YOU'LL
BE BACK BECAUSE WE'LL BE
TALKING ABOUT THIS AGAIN- WHEN
WE WHEN WE- START REVIEWING ALL
THAT MATERIAL FOR THAT- MAY
REVISE SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND I. APPRECIATE IT. WE'RE ALL
WAITING WITH BATED BREATH TO
SEE WHAT'S IN THERE MAY REVISE-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN- WHICH IS-
IT UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF BUSINESS AND DEVELOPMENT- GO
BIZ. AND IT IS SUPPORT FOR
UNDERSERVED FINANCIAL MARKETS.
WHEN ASKED THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST TO PLEASE PRESENT ON
THIS ITEM. GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
BRAND WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND I WILL BE INTRODUCING THE
SENATE DEMOCRATS PLAN FOR
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY THE- COVE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND THE FIRST
ITEM IN THIS PACKAGE IS ISSUE
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN. SO THIS IS
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS BUDGET
PLAN TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
UNDERSERVED FINANCIAL MARKETS.
AS DESCRIBED IN THE AGENDA THIS
ITEM HAS TWO COMPONENTS. THE
FIRST COMPONENT WOULD PROVIDE
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME TO FIND A NEW GRANT
PROGRAM. TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS OR CDFI IS. CITY
OF FIZER PRIVATE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT PROVIDE FINANCIAL PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
UNDERSERVED BY TRADITIONAL
FINANCIAL MARKETS. AS DESCRIBED
IN THE AGENDA THE SENATE PLAN
WOULD CREATE A NEW COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA INVESTMENTS AND
INNOVATION PROGRAM WHICH WOULD
BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BANKER I
THINK. UNDER THIS NEW PROGRAM
SIGNIFIES REPLY TO I THANK FOR
GRANTS GRANT FUNDING WOULD-
MIGHT BE USED FOR A WIDE RANGE
OF USES FOR EXAMPLE TO MAKE
LOANS TO MAKE EQUITY
INVESTMENTS. THE GRANTS OULD
ALSO BE USED TO FUND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS OPERATED BY
THE CITY OF FIGHTS. AND THE
SECOND COMPONENT OF THIS- ITEM
WOULD PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME TO THE
FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT FUND
WHICH IS USED TO MAKE GRANTS TO
NONPROFITS SERVING UNBANKED AND
UNDERBANKED CALIFORNIANS. THIS
PROGRAM IS ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION.
GRANTS MADE UNDER THIS PROGRAM
CAN BE USED TO PROVIDE FREE
FINANCIAL EDUCATION AND OTHER
SERVICES. I AM SOMEWHAT LIMITED
IN MY ABILITY TO PROVIDE.
COMMENTS ON THIS PROPOSAL THAT
SAID I WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS TO CLARIFY MY REMARKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT TIME
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM. ONE OF
OUR PANELISTS SIR ARE. RIGHT
ROSE ABI. THANK YOU WELCOME
THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK MY NAME IS SARAH
RESOLVING I AM THE CEO OF
WORKING SOLUTIONS CDFI. WE'RE A
NONPROFIT CDFI BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO SERVING THE LARGER
NINE BAY AREA REGION OUR
ORGANIZATION PROVIDE START UP
AND EARLY STAGE MICROLOANS
COUPLED WITH CONSULTING AT
SMALL BUSINESS ENTREPRENEURS.
AS MISSION DRIVEN LENDERS WE
SERVE THOSE WHO ARE
MARGINALIZED BY THE FINANCIAL
MAINSTREAM ESPECIALLY LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS WOMEN AND
ENTREPRENEURS OF COLOR. BUT I'M
HERE TODAY AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
COMMUNITY INVESTMENT A
COALITION OF MORE THAN THIRTY
CALIFORNIA CDS SIZE OF
DIFFERENT SIZES AND WITH
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS RANGING FROM
SMALL BUSINESS LENDING REAL
ESTATE AND MORE BUT WHAT ALIGNS
US IS A COMMITMENT TO BRINGING
EQUITABLE INVESTMENT TO UNDER
RESOURCED COMMUNITIES AND
WORKING TO OVERCOME. HISTORIC
PATTERNS OF DISINVESTMENT. I AM
PLEASED TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL. AS A
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA NAVIGATES
ITS WAY OUT OF THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE LEVERAGE THE
STATE'S UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET
SURPLUS TO BUILD A JUST AND
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND TO BUILD THE PERMANENT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUSTAIN THE
RECOVERY. AND EXPAND
OPPORTUNITY. THE CDFI MODEL I
CAPITAL OVER OF. PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE TO BE LEVERAGED FOR THE
BENEFIT OF INDIVIDUALS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT HISTORICALLY
HAVE LACKED ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE INVESTMENT.
CALIFORNIA MAY USE THAT SURPLUS
NOT ONLY FOR ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS BUT TO CREATE THE
LONG TERM INFRASTRUCTURE
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT REAL
CHANGE IN COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
STRUGGLING BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
CATCH AND TO MAYBE LEFT FARTHER
BEHIND IF WE DO NOT ACT IN
COORDINATION. THAT MEANS
SUPPORTING THE MERRY OUT OF
INVESTMENT CDFI COLLECTIVELY.
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ENTREPRENEURS
DELIVERED DELIVERING HOUSING
HEALTH CARE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ALSO BUILDING FINANCIAL
SECURITY FOR FAMILIES. THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS A MODEST
INVESTMENT IN A LONG TERM
STRATEGY TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA INVESTMENT AND
INNOVATION PROGRAM. WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH A CDFI FUND IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD LEVERAGE
THE RESOURCES AND INNOVATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S CDFI IS TO BRING
CRITICAL INVESTMENT TO
COMMUNITIES IN NEED. THIS
PROGRAM AS OUTLINED IN THE
CHAIR IS SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
FIVE WHICH WE HAVE BEEN PLEASED
TO SUPPORT. THE PROPOSAL IS
ACTUALLY MODELED AFTER THAT
VERY SUCCESSFUL FEDERAL CDFI
FUND PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY
THE US TREASURY DEPARTMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM WOULD
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED FLEXIBLE
CAPITAL TO CALIFORNIA SIGNIFIES
TO MAKE LOANS AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS CONSUMERS AND EVEN
COMMUNITIES ADDRESSING CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS SUCH AS
SAFE DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS.
THE INVESTMENT PROPOSED IN THIS
BUDGET ITEM WOULD BE LEVERAGED
AT THREE TO ONE MEANING THAT
CDFI IS COULD USE EVERY DOLLAR
THE STATE INVEST TO DELIVER
THREE DOLLARS FOR CRITICAL
COMMUNITY PROJECTS. IN ADDITION
THIS BUDGET ITEM WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO THE
FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT FUND A
PROGRAM CREATED BY SENATOR
BRADFORD'S SP FOUR FIFTY FIVE
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. THE FUND
SAYS UNBANKED AND UNDERBANKED
CONSUMERS ACCESS RESPONSIBLE
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS BUILD CREDIT
AND ACCESS FREE FINANCIAL
EDUCATION. WE APPRECIATE THE
BUDGETS ARE STATEMENTS OF OUR
VALUES AND TOGETHER THESE TWO
MODEST INVESTMENTS WILL HELP
DEVELOP A CHEST AND STENA BULK
ECONOMIC RECOVERY BY DELIVERING
LONG TERM RESOURCES TO
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA CDFI INDUSTRY.
OTHER STATES INCLUDING NEW YORK
AND VIRGINIA HAVE ALREADY
INSTITUTED STATES CDFI FINES
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE A SIMILAR
STEP. WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THESE CRITICAL ELEMENTS OF THE
STATE'S BUDGET AND AGAIN I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. SENATOR
NELSON YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR- I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATED YOUR PRESENTATION
SERVER RED SOX RAYS ABI- IN THE-
EIGHT THE ABILITY. TO LEVERAGE.
PRECIOUS STATE RESOURCES WHICH
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND PARTICULARLY IN
THESE AREAS- AROUND HOUSING
HEALTH CARE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
I THINK ALL OF THAT IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AND THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF UNBANKED AND
UNDERBANKED INDIVIDUALS IS- IS
LONG STANDING AND PART OF THE
CHALLENGE IS THAT IF YOU DON'T
HAVE. A CREDIT IF YOU DON'T DO
IT IN OUR SYSTEM IS- IS
DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU IN ORDER
TO HAVE GOOD CREDIT YOU HAVE TO
BORROW. WHICH DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE YOU COULD PAY ALL YOUR
BILLS IN CASH ON TIME AND YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY CREDIT AND SO
THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY GET OUT
AND TEACH PEOPLE HOW THAT ALL
WORKS AND THEN THE-
RESPONSIBILITY OF MAKING
REGULAR PAYMENTS IN ORDER TO
GET GOOD CREDIT. THAT THEN
ALLOWS YOU TO GET THE LOWER-
WERE AT. LOWER INTEREST RATES
AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT COMES
UP THAT IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT AND HOW YOU CAN LOSE
CREDIT JUST BY CO SIGNING. ALL
OF THAT IS- IT'S FAIRLY
INTERPRET INTRICATE AND IS- IT
IS NOT. LOGICAL SYSTEM IS NOT
BASED ON LOGIC WHICH IS THAT IF
I PAY ALL MY BILLS ON TIME THAT
I SHOULD HAVE REALLY GOOD
CREDIT- SO IN PARTICULAR
IMMIGRANTS COMING FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES. THAT HAVE THE- A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM FIND IT VERY
VERY DIFFICULT TO. MANAGE I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY AND-
AND THE KINDS OF RESOURCES THAT
THAT ON THIS PARTICULAR.
EXPENDITURE WOULD PROVIDE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU YES THE CDS I
INDUSTRY IS WELL AWARE OF THE
COMMUNITIES YOU'RE REFERRING TO
SENATOR AND- I THINK IT'S IT
GOES TO STATE THAT
TRANSLITERATED TO CEOS OF MAJOR
BANKS CHARLIE SCHARF AND OF
WELLS FARGO. AND BUILT IN CHECK
OF PNC SENT THAT SIGNIFIES ARE
ONE OF THE KEY INVESTMENT
APPROACHES THEY ARE USING TO
COMBAT RACIAL INEQUITY AND
RESTORE THE ECONOMY. SO THAT
SPEAKS TO THE POINT AROUND
LEVERAGE- WE REALLY ARE WELL
POISED TO WORK WITH BOTH
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC. SUPPORT TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY UNDER
BANKED AND UNDER RESOURCE- ARE
LIFTED UP. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT APPRECIATE
IT AND IF WE REALLY WANT TO
MAKE A DENT IN. THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT. CAN SOMEDAY
BUY A HOME THIS IS GOING TO BE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. AS WE ROLL OUT OUR
FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS PROGRAM
THAT WE ALSO HAVE THIS
ALONGSIDE IT. TO HELP THE WHOLE
PROCESS WORK A LOT BETTER SO
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM- WE'LL
SEE THIS BACK IN THE FUTURE AND
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY- WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT WHICH IS
MICROBICIDES. RELIEF FUND. AND
IF I COULD- ASK. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
BRAIN WITH WEATHERFORD AGAIN
TO- THIS ITEM. YES ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY EIGHT IS THE SENATE'S
BUDGET PLAN TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
STATE'S SMALLEST BUSINESS. THE
FEDERAL PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM AND CALIFORNIA'S COVED
NINETEEN RELIEF GRANTS HAVE
PROVIDED SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESSES THAT WERE AFFECTED
BY THE COBIT NINETEEN TEN
DEMOCRATS. HOWEVER. IN THESE
FUNDS AS DESCRIBED IN THE
AGENDA THE SENATE'S BUDGET PLAN
INCLUDES FUNDING FOR A NEW
STATEWIDE MICRO BUSINESS RELIEF
FUND THIS NEW PROGRAM COULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
TO SIDEWALK VENDORS AND OTHER
INFORMAL BUSINESSES THAT ALSO
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WOULD WOULD NOW LIKE TO TURN
THE MIKE OVER TO RUDY ESPINOZA
WHO'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
INCLUSIVE ACTION FOR THE CITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS IN THE LAST ITEM. I
HAD ADDED OUR GONNA DEFINITELY-
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS RUDY ESPINOZA AND I. SERVIZI
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF INCLUSIVE
ACTION WE ARE ALSO COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCE INSTITUTION
BUT BASED IN LOS ANGELES. THAT
WORKS TO BUILD STRONG LOCAL
ECONOMIES THROUGH ADVOCACY BUT
ALSO LOW INTEREST FINANCE WE
BELIEVE CREDIT- ACCESSIBILITY
IS KEY TO OUR COMMUNITIES WE
PROVIDE MICROLOANS TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN WORKING HARD DURING THIS
TIME TO SERVE MY CROTCH FOR
NORRIS. WE'VE BEEN IN MINISTRY
CASH RELIEF PROGRAMS EVEN
VACCINE CLINICS SO I WANNA GIVE
A SHOUT OUT IN IN THANK YOU TO
SENATOR COM LAGER FOR
SUPPORTING OUR CLINIC I'M A
CRAZY MORNING WAS TRICKING YOUR
DISTRICT WE WERE ABLE TO
VACCINATE OVER FIVE HUNDRED-
WORKER AND STREET VENDORS- IN
YOUR DISTRICT- WITH YOUR
HEALTH. I'M I'M HERE TODAY TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER
SUPPORTING MICRO BUSINESSES IN
INFORMAL ENTREPRENEURS WITH THE
CREATION OF THIS DEDICATED
GRANT PROGRAM. THERE'S SO MUCH
NEED IN CALIFORNIA THIS COULD
REALLY HELP. FOR OVERTEN YEARS
MY ORGANIZATION AND MANY OTHERS
HAVE WORKED TO CREATE PATHWAYS
FOR MICRO ENTREPRENEURS WHO
OPERATE BUSINESSES IN THE OPEN
AIR ECONOMY THE SELF CREW TALK
WAS QUOTING A CULTURAL GOODS
AND OTHER ITEMS TO TEACHER
THEIR FAMILIES. IN LA WE SEE
THAT MANY OF THE STREET VENDORS
THAT WE WORK WITH ARE WOMEN IN
THE MAJORITY ARE REALLY LOW
INCOME BUT DESPITE THEIR
INDIVIDUAL CHALLENGES AS A
COMMUNITY OF MICROCHIP OR NOR
IS THE GENERATOR OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN LA ALONE.
I MEAN I'M SURE THEY ADDED THAT
NUMBERS A LOT BIGGER WHEN WE
WHEN WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
COMMUNITIES AND CITIES AND
TOWNS ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY INFORMAL
BUSINESSES LIKE STREET VENDORS
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN REALLY BAD
IN IT HARD AND IT MAKES NO
SURPRISE THERE ARE THESE
CLASSES SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
WERE LEADING ONE CRISIS AWAY
FROM LOSING THEIR HOUSE SCENE
AND POINTED TO SEE IF YOUR DAD
BEFORE THIS AND THAT MAKES. AND
NOW THE CRISIS HAS COME IN THE
CRISIS LASTED OVER A YEAR AND
MANY. HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING. AS
A RESULT OF THE EMERGENCY
HEALTH ORDERS THAT THEY TOOK
PLACE IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. ACROSS THE STREET
MANY WORK VAN FROM SELLING.
OTHER AS YOU KNOW SENATE BILL
NYE FORTY SO CREATED A
FRAMEWORK FOR CITIES TO CREATE.
THIS FOR SIDE VENDOR. BUT THE
PANDEMIC IN THESE EMERGE.
HEALTH ORDERS- D. RAY. A LOT OF
THE HOAX OF A LOT OF. DENIS C.
TO KEEP THEIR PER IN AKWA. I
TOOK MANY STREET VENDORS WE'LL
HAVE BEEN ANYWAY ACCESS SMALL
BUSINESS. YOU KNOW GRAHAM
PROGRAMS I DO LOOKING FOR SOME
ELSE THEY LOOKING A DIFFERENT.
TO GET THE RELIEF THAT THEY
NEED. MANY BEEN SO TO. WITH
WELL RESOURCE BUSINESS TO GET
TO THAT THE GRAHAM PROGRAMS IN
OF YOU HAVE ESTABLISH DURING
THIS TIME AND THEN WE'VE NEED
BEEN ASSISTING FOLKS TO TRY TO
GET THROUGH- MINISTRY. VENDORS
THAT WE WORK WITH I'M HAVE TO
GIVEN UP HOPE AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT BEEN REALLY SAD
SEE HERE FOLKS. YOU KNOW WHAT I
JUST I DON'T TO TRY AGAIN I
JUST DON'T THINK I'M GET A
CHECK TO GET. A GET US INTO THE
RELEASE DATE THAT I NEED. TO
MAKE MATTERS YOU WILL PROBABLY
KNOW THIS BEEN A- BY. AGAIN US.
BEEN AND OTHER OF. I JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO WE PROBABLY THE
HEADLINE AND FRED ALL THIS
GOING TO GO SHOT. STYLE BY THE
WAY WORKING I MEAN ME THE IS
JUST. THIS IS JUST. OF THE BIO
OUT OF POVERTY IN THE BY IS TO
PLACE IN OUR- BUT ALSO. IT
REMINDS ME THAT WE NEEDED CARE
OF OUR TRIP. THAT THEY NEED IN
THE COLOR RIGHT AWAY NO OKAY
VERY KIND TO ME. WE NATURE THAT
THEY- THAT THEIR VALUED PART OF
OUR
PROPOSAL FOR YOU- YEAH ITEM
FORTY EIGHT HERE- YOU NEED YOUR
SUPPORT. IT PROPOSES FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM
THAT IS DEDICATED TO
ENTREPRENEURS IN THE INFORMAL
ECONOMY LIKE STREET VENDORS AND
OTHER MICRO BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET. HELP
FROM OTHER OTHER PROGRAMS. IT
OFFERS THE PROPOSALS A FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANTS AND
THAT'S HUGE. AND YOU KNOW THE
MONEY WE BELIEVE CAN HELP
ENTREPRENEURS CATER DEBTS BUT
ALSO ACQUIRE PERMITS IN NEW
EQUIPMENT SO THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE ECONOMY. WE
JUST WE CAN'T HAVE A CHEST
RECOVERY WITHOUT THE MICRON
SUPPORTERS IMMIGRANT
NEIGHBORHOODS VIBRANT. AND IN-
WE THINK THAT YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER REALLY SUPPORTING
THIS- FOR ME THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT HOW WE WOULD
ADMINISTER THESE RESOURCES. I
THINK THE CDFI IS CONCERNED WE
HELP ADMINISTER THESE RESOURCE.
BUT ALSO OTHER COMMUNITY BASED.
EACH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND- THIS IS
EXCITING. IT'S AN EXCITING
POTENTIAL HERE. SO THAT'S IT-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
I KNOW YOU ALL HAVE MANY
COMPETING PRIORITIES BUT I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT IF YOU DO
NOT. SURE THE MOST VULNERABLE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY
MICROCHIPPING NORRIS WERE
CREATING THEIR OWN JOBS. IN OUR
ECONOMY CAN BE AS STRONG AS IT
CAN BE. YOU KNOW AND SO I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER THIS
SERIOUSLY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'M HERE
FOR YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM LUKE
PARDEW WHOSE THE ECONOMIST. AT
COASTAL. I. THANK YOU ARE CHECK
OUT THE ERROR AND- SUBCOMMITTEE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
LUKE PARTY- I AM AN ECONOMIST
AT GUSTO RESEARCHING HOW SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN BE BOLSTERED BY
PUBLIC POLICIES GUSTO IS A
CAMPUS THE SCHOOL BASED PEOPLE.
PLATFORM EIGHT FIVE PROVIDES.
BENEFITS COME AND X. EXPERT HR
MORE THAN FIVE SMALL. AND HELP
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. BECAUSE
THIS MISSION IS TO CREATE A
WORLD WHERE WORK EMPOWERS A
BETTER LIFE AND WE ARE DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO HELPING LAUNCH.
NORTH CANTON POLICE ARRIVE. OUR
GOAL IS TO AMPLIFY THE VOICES
OF SMALL BUSINESSES. AND TO
ADVOCATE. FOR HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. I
WANTED TO PROVIDE TODAY SOME
DATABASE INSIGHTS ON THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PROPOSED BUDGET
PRIORITIES FOR SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF. NAMELY THE SPORT FOR
THE CDFI FUNDING TO
RECAPITALIZE THESE
INSTITUTIONS. AND SUPPORT FOR
THE MICRO BUSINESS RELIEF FUND
WHICH WOULD PROVIDE GRANTS TO
THE SMALLEST BUSINESSES THAT
ARE NOT ABLE TO ACCESS OTHER
SOURCES OF FUNDING. FOR THAT R.
TWO RESOURCE CONSTRAINED TO
PURSUE ANY AND ALL SOURCES OF
EIGHT- SELECTIVE YOU WITH. SOME
REAL TIME DATA FROM GUSTO THAT
UNDERSCORES THE NEED FOR THESE
POLICIES AND I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME EMERGING
DISPARITIES THAT REINFORCED THE
IMPORTANCE OF ALLOCATING
RESPONSE EQUITABLY. ACROSS THE
STATE PARTICULARLY TO THOSE I
HARD HIT INDUSTRIES AND
GEOGRAPHIC AREA. THESE INSIGHTS
COME FROM CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES USING US THOSE
PAYROLL SOFTWARE WHICH INCLUDES
FIRMS ACROSS ALL INDUSTRIES
FROM RESTAURANTS AND RETAIL
SHOPS TO DOCTORS OFFICES IN
CHILD CARE CENTERS. MORE THAN
90% OF OUR CUSTOMERS ARE FEWER
THAN FIFTEEN EMPLOYEES SO THE
STATE CAN BE SEEN AS A SNAPSHOT
OF. THE STATE OF MICRO BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW.
THROUGH APRIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THIS PAST MONTH MICRO
BUSINESSES IN THESE HARD HIT
INDUSTRIES WHICH INCLUDE
PERSONAL SERVICES. MAJOR IN
HOSPITALITY. STILL STRUGGLING
TO SURVIVE OR COMPLAINANT DOWN
15% COMPARED TO FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY RIGHT BEFORE THE
END OF A CAT. LOOKING AT A FEW
SECTORS IN PARTICULAR MICRO
BUSINESSES BEING A TOURISM
INDUSTRY A VITAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY I HAVE YET
TO RECOVER ONE THIRD OF THEIR
PRE CAN'T MAKE HEAD COUNT.
CHECK BEEN SIMILARLY HARD HIT.
AND SALONS AND ARE STILL DOWN
25% RELATIVE TO FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY. SECOND EVEN WITHIN THIS
GROUP OF MICRO BUSINESSES ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES THERE ARE
LARGE DISPARITIES ACROSS FIRM
SIZES. MOST NOTABLY FIRMS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH FEWER THAN FIVE
EMPLOYEES. HAVE CONTINUED TO
SHED JOBS EVEN AS LARGER
BUSINESSES AFTER A PERIOD OF
GROWTH AND RECOVERY. FINALLY I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME ALARMING
DISPARITIES ACROSS GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS COMBINING DUSTED
EMPLOYMENT DTA WITH
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION ON
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES WE SEE
THAT EMPLOYMENT UP SMALL
BUSINESSES BEEN MAJORITY BY
PARK COUNTY APPLE INC THREE
TIMES MORE ACCOUNTS IN THE REST
OF THE STATE. AND EMPLOYMENT IN
COUNTIES WITH ABOVE AVERAGE
SHARES OF. HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE
LIVING IN SPEAKING OUR HOUSE.
ARE DOWN FOR TIMES THAN THE
REST F THE STATE. PUTTING THIS
ONE TOGETHER WAS IT HIGHLIGHTS
THE NEED FOR A- TO THESE
MICROBES. AND FOR THE X. RAYS
TO BE PART TO THOSE HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND BY LARGER. SUCH AS
THE COULD CHECK GROUP. THE
SMALLEST OF THE SMALL BIT ARE
STILL TO I'M OUR PARTICULAR
STRUGGLING SECTORS SUCH THAT
WERE HARDEST HIT. AND OUR
COMMUNITY. CONTINUE TO BE
HARDSHIP HI THIS RECESSION. A
FEW SUGGESTIONS FOR THIS MICRO
GRANTS PROGRAM. IN TERMS OF
WITH TO MAKE IS ELIGIBLE RIGHT
ARE STILL AS FAR. TO ALLOW AS
MANY FORMS OF THE- AS POSSIBLE
AND TO ENSURE. THAT
APPLICATIONS ARE IN LINE WITH
OTHER ENGLISH LIKE HER ARE A
NOW. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT GET
DATA UP TO. G. AREAS THAT
INDUSTRIES. WHEN USED TOGETHER
PUBLIC PRIVATE DATA SOURCES CAN
PROVIDE A REAL TIME POLLS ON
ECONOMIC INEQUALITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND HIS FINDINGS CAN
BE INCORPORATED INTO FORMULAS
ALLOCATE THESE WERE RESPONSE.
HERE AS AN EXAMPLE WHY WOULD I
HAVE BEEN USING TOURISM BOTH
HAVE FUN SET ASIDE FOR DIRECTED
RECOVERY EFFORTS. OUR DATA
SHOWS THAT SALONS AND SPAS HAVE
BEEN JUST AS HARD HIT AND HAVE
BEEN LARGELY OVERLOOKED. IN
TARGETED IT AFTERWARDS RECEIVE
CLA OUR SYSTEM OF SALON WORKERS
ARE NEARLY 76% ASIAN 80% EMAIL
SO THIS IS A MATTER OF GENDER.
EQUITY GENDER AND RACIAL EQUITY
IN ADDITION. TO BEING GOOD
ECONOMIC SENSE. THESE POLICIES.
THAT PROVIDE TARGET A TWO BY
PRO BUSINESS. OUR CREW STEPS TO
BUILDING AN EQUITABLE RECOVERY
IS A GOOD OF ALL HEALTH. AND I
HOPE THAT'S THE BETTER CAN I
INFORM EFFORTS THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO AND
I'VE GOT TO TAKE A QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TEST. OF THE SUGGESTIONS IN
TERMS OF MAKING THAT PROGRAM
STRONGER MY CFI THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS ANY COMMENTS ON
THIS ITEM. I SHOULD HAVE ASKED
YOU ON THE LAST MY APOLOGIES.
HELLO TO PARK TOMORROW JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT FINANCE WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
OKAY VERY GOOD HOW ABOUT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE HAVE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
VERY GOOD BRING IT BACK TO-
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. BUT WE
ARE WE'RE ON THE MICRO BUSINESS
S. R. SENATOR NELSON LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION. MADAM CHAIRMAN.
IT IS NOT A JUVENILE. QUESTION
FOR THESE DAYS AND TIMES WHAT
IS DEFINED AS STATUTORILY OR
LEGALLY AS A QUOTE MICRO
BUSINESS. GOOD QUESTION I THINK
WE MAY HAVE DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT IDEAS OF WHAT IT
ENTAILS BASED ON A- BASED ON
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE SO
MAYBE I COULD ASK- THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
SO ONE COMMON DEFINITION OF A
MICRO BUSINESSES IF YOU WERE
THAN TEN EMPLOYEES I BELIEVE
THAT- HAS BEEN USED BY THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION-
BUT I'M NOT SURE- THAT DID THAT
YOU MENTIONED- CHECKUP THERE
THERE'S MORE THAN ONE
DEFINITION OF A MICRO BUSINESS.
WELL I THINK. WHERE IS THAT
DOWN IS THAT IN THE CODE BOOK
IS THAT IN A MEMO BOOK IS IT IN
A STORYBOOK EIGHT IS IT IN A
REGULATION THERE'S A RUSH
STATUTORY FOUNDATION FOR A
MICRO BUSINESS. WHAT'S THE
LEGAL FOUNDATION. FORTIETH. IF
THAT'S A QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
CAN- I'M NOT AWARE OF A
STATUTORY DEFINITION OF A MICRO
BUSINESS BUT WE CAN- LOOK INTO
THAT AND GET BACK TO YOU AND
YOUR STAFF WELL YES WE'RE
TALKING ALL ABOUT DOING THINGS
FOR MICRO BUSINESSES BUT WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT OR WHO
WE'RE DOING THINGS FOR. THAT'S
NOT A VERY GOOD WAY TO PROCEED
SO PLEASE IF YOU'D BE SO KIND.
WE'LL GET TO THAT DEFINITION
SENATOR I THINK- S. EIGHT YOU
MAY REMEMBER THAT- WHEN WE WERE
DOING OUR SMALL BUSINESS GRANT.
PROGRAM THAT WE HAD DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT. TRYING TO REACH DEEPER
INTO THE SMALL BUSINESS SECTOR.
AND THERE WERE A NUMBER OF- OF
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES AND I
THINK THE ONE OF THE TESTIMONY-
WHAT IS THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF. PEOPLE WHO HAVE THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES BETTER- BETTER HOME
BUSINESSES SO THEY COOK AT HOME
AND THEN THEY SELL OUT OF THE
BACK OF A TRUCK OR THE ID CODE
YOU KNOW TO BUSINESSES- THE
TAMALE LADY COMES TO MIND TO
MIND BUT ALSO- THERE ARE ALL OF
THE VENDORS THAT THAT SELL
FRUIT OUT OF THE BACK OF A
TRUCK. THEY SELL ICE CREAM BE
IT WITH THE LITTLE CARDS THAT
ARE INDIVIDUAL PARTS MAYBE EVEN
THE ICE CREAM AND WEAR THEIR-
THEIR THEIR THEIR THEIR OWN
BUSINESS- AND THEY DON'T HAVE.
A THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE
TO- THINK CORP INCORPORATOR TO
BE YOU KNOW FOLLOW THE KINDS OF
A BUSINESS PROCESS BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE. THEY'RE MICRO
IF YOU WILL- WHAT WE WANT TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BUSINESSES.
THAT HAVE STOPPED OPERATING
ENTIRELY- IT'S ALSO THE TACO
TRUCKS MEET IT AS WELL- THEN
THEY HAVE AN ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PROGRAM WHERE
THEY THEY COULD ALSO ACCESS
GRANT FUNDS- WE DID NOT INCLUDE
THEM IN THE- IN THE SMALL
BUSINESS GRANT PROGRAM BECAUSE
WE JUST COULDN'T- FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO BE ABLE TO REACH THAT
FAR INTO THE- INTO THE SMALL
BUSINESS- AT. AT AREA AND SO
THIS I THINK IS THE RESPONSE TO
THAT BUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DEFINE WHAT CONSTITUTES A MICRO
BUSINESS- AND I WOULD EXPECT
THAT IF YOU WERE ELIGIBLE UNDER
THE OTHER PROGRAM YOU WOULDN'T
BE ELIGIBLE UNDER THIS PROGRAM-
BUT- THIS IS. AN ITEM THAT IS A
I BELIEVE IT'S A- HOLD OPEN
ITEM SO IT MORE ON THAT LATER.
BUT THE IDEA IS TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE IDENTIFY
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE HAD
A SMALL BUSINESS IF THEY THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THAT. A LOCATION
READ THAT THEY'RE PAYING AND
STAFF THAT THEY'RE PAYING AND
SO THIS IS THE ATTEMPT TO REACH
THEM SO WE HEAR YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN I THINK WE THIS IS A
SENATE PROPOSAL- WE LEFT SOME
PEOPLE OUT OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS GRANT PROGRAM AND WE
WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE CAPTURING
THEM. I UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
VERY CLEAR BUT I THINK IN TIME
TERMS OF THE TACO TRACTION
GESTURE. THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT.
DEFINITELY THERE. AND YOU KNOW
IN MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT I THINK
THE TESTIMONY FROM- LA WAS THAT
IT'S A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR CONTRIBUTION TO THEIR
LOCAL ECONOMY. IT SAYS IT SAYS
THAT SIGNIFICANT AERO
CALIFORNIA. THOSE ARE THE THAT
USUALLY THEY'RE THAT THE-
BUSINESSES THAT GROW OVER TIME
AND THAT. THEN END UP. RENTING
A LOCATION AND SERVING. SERVING
MEALS AND- AND OTHER ACTIVITIES
SO- WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE WE'RE CAPTURING THEM
SO I'M- I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
I'M I THINK THIS IS A- A REALLY
GOOD IDEA AND I. I DO THINK
THERE'S MORE MORE INFORMATION
COMING SO. I THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT QUESTION SENATOR- THAT
CONCLUDES THIS IS A HOLD OPEN
ITEM. SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FORTY NINE.
WHICH IS LIVE EVENTS GRANTS AND
ARTS AND CULTURE INVESTMENT.
AND DONNA LET ME SEE HERE WE'LL
GO FIRST TO. BRIAN WEATHERFORD
FROM THE- THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. HELLO AGAIN-
FRIEND WHETHER FORD LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY NINE IS THE SENATE'S
BUDGET PLAN TO CREATE A NEW
GRANT PROGRAM FOR LIFE EVENT
VENUES PERFORMING ARTS VENUES
AND RELATED. BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I SHOULD SAY
RELATED BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS- AS
DESCRIBED IN THE AGENDA THIS
LIVE VENUES GRANT PROGRAM WOULD
BE SIMILAR TO THE NON PROFIT
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS COMPONENT
OF THE COVERT NINETEEN RELIEF
GRANT PROGRAM. IS ADMINISTERED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. ELIGIBLE
BUSINESSES COULD INCLUDE
ENTITIES WHOSE PRIMARY BUSINESS
ACTIVITY. IS ORGANIZING OR
HOSTING LIVE EVENTS OR WHO ARE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE TO SIGNIFY
THE END WHO ARE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE A SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE LOSS DURING THE LAST
THREE QUARTERS OF TWENTY TWENTY
AS COMPARED TO TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE LIVE VENUES GRANT PROGRAM
IS ONE PART OF A LARGER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS SENATE PLAN TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE STATE'S CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES. AND THE OTHER PARTS
OF THIS PLAN INCLUDE FUNDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL TO
EXPAND ITS GRANT. GRANT
PROGRAMS. FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS TO EMPLOY CREATIVE
WORKERS AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND LASTLY FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL AND
HISTORICAL INDICTMENT AND THOSE
FUNDS MIGHT BE USED FOR THE
ACQUISITION RESTORATION
PRESERVATION AND INTERPRETATION
OF CALIFORNIA'S HISTORICAL.
CULTURAL AND NATURAL RESOURCES
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
ON THIS ISSUE. VERY GOOD- I'D
LIKE AND NOW LIKE TO- INVITE
CASEY LAUTER MELK WHO IS CO
FOUNDER OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF NATIONAL INDEPENDENT
VENUE ASSOCIATION. GREAT THANK
YOU COPYRIGHT I WAS HOPING TO
HAVE JULIE BAKER WITH
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES TO
SPEAK FIRST YEAR SHE CAN BE ON
US ALL WE CAN DO THAT WE'LL
START WITH JULIE BAKER WHO'S
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE ARTS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO SPEAK
TODAY IN THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA ARTS
CULTURE AND CREATIVE%
INDUSTRIES. AND THANK YOU FOR
HIGHLIGHTING SUPPORT FOR GRANTS
FOR INDEPENDENT VENUES AND
OTHER BUSINESSES THAT FOCUS ON
LIVE EVENTS IN THE SENATE'S
BUDGET PRIORITIES FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AS I STATED MY
NAME IS JIM BAKER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA OUR TOP
AGAINST TODAY REPRESENTING A
BROAD COALITION WITH NEVA
CALIFORNIA. IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF EASY MUSEUMS
RECENTLY OVER FIVE HUNDRED
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS MUSEUMS AND
INDEPENDENT VENUES SIGNED A
LETTER CALLING GOVERNOR KNEW
SOME. OF THE CALIFORNIA LET'S
STATE LEGISLATOR TO MAKE A BOLD
TRANSFORMATIONAL ONE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT OVER THE NEXT
TWO TO FOUR YEARS. IN THE ARTS
CULTURE THE CREATIVE ECONOMY IN
OVER THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS SENT LETTERS TO
EVERY DISTRICT OFFICE IN
CALIFORNIA. URGING THE SAME
SUPPORT. THE CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
DIVERSE AND IMPACTFUL
REPRESENTING OVER 7% OF THE
GROSS STATE PRODUCT FOR THE
STATE OVER. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
REVENUE. THE CONSTRUCTION
ENTRANCE. INDUSTRIES AND IT IS
GOING. SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND WORKERS. SINCE MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY OF THE
INDUSTRY'S SUFFERED WIDESPREAD
ECONOMIC DEVASTATION WELL SOME
REALLY JUST COME THE DATA SHOWS
THAT MANY BUSINESSES. ARTS
WORKERS OR SURVIVORS RECURRING
DEBT DEPLETING THEIR SAVINGS
LEAVING THE INDUSTRY AND SOME
EVEN LEAVING THE STATE. STUDIES
ALSO CONFIRM THERE'S
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT AND
LACK OF ACCESS TO FUNDING AND
RESOURCES. TO RURAL COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IF WE
DON'T LOOK TO REBUILD THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES PIPELINE
CALIFORNIA COULD BE FACING A
CULTURAL DEPRESSION. OTHER
COMMUNITIES REOPENED WE KNOW
ARTS CULTURE AND CREATIVITY
WILL BE AN ESSENTIAL INDUSTRY
TO BRING SOCIAL COHESION.
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT AND
WELLNESS JOBS CREATION SOCIAL
IMPACT AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOU. SINCE MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIFTY NINE PERCENT. OF
CREATIVE WORKERS HAVE BEEN MADE
UNEMPLOYED AND ARE SUFFERING
FROM A LACK OF MUST BE BASIC
HUMAN NEEDS IN FACT THERE ARE
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
WORKFORCE AMONG US. OVERALL
INDUSTRY REVENUE LOSSES
ESTIMATED AT FORTY THREE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS WITH OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS
IMPACTED. AND A LOSS OF ABOUT
SIX AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
THE STATE AND LOCAL TAXES WE
NEED TO BRING THIS REVENUE BACK
TO CALIFORNIA. AND ALTHOUGH THE
SITUATION IS URGENT AND DIRE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES WE BELIEVE THERE IS
A SOLUTION TO NOT ONLY HELP US
SURVIVE. BUT THRIVE AND SUPPORT
THE OVERALL JUST FOR COVERAGE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS WE ALREADY
HAVE THE AGENCIES TO MAKE THE
GRANTS HAPPEN WE JUST NEED TO
DOUBLE DOWN AND MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS. STATE SENATORS BEN
ALLEN AND SUSAN RUBIO AND STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE FREE
MENTORING IS ARIANNA SHARON
QUIRK SILVA. THE MERGE IS A
LEADING LEGISLATIVE CHAMPIONS
FOR THIS ONE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. WE HOPE YOU WILL
JOIN THEM. CALIFORNIA HAS ONCE
IN. OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN
THE ART AND STAY. AT HER STORE
UNDER. SECTOR OF THE OF CALM.
CURRENTLY HELD FOR BASS SEVENTY
CENTS CAPITA STATE ARTS FUNDING
COMPARED THAT TO YOUR OVER TO.
AND THIRTY CENTS A MINUTE AND
OVER SIX DOLLARS CALIFORNIA
STATE SHOULD LEADING CREATIVE
INVESTMENT IS LAGGING BEHIND.
IN ADDITION THE ONLY STATEWIDE
SON FIND FUNDING SOURCE FOR
ARTISTS TO BE AVAILABLE IN
EVERY COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA.
IS THE STATE ARTS AGENCY THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL FUNDING
THIS AGENCY IS AN EQUITY ISSUE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE ARTS. WE SUPPORT
A MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT OF FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANTS AS PART OF THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. ASKED
SPECIFICALLY SPORTING COMMUNITY
ACCESS TO ARTS PROGRAM WITH A
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION OVER THREE YEARS. AS
A ONE TIME INCREASE TO THE
CURRENT GENERAL FUND THE C. AC
SIX FAN EXISTING GET
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND UNDER FUNDED
PROGRAMS. INCLUDING CULTURAL
DISTRICTS ARTS IN SCHOOLS ARTS
AND VETERANS AND CORRECTIONS
AND NONPROFIT GENERAL OPERATING
SUPPORT. AND TO ESTABLISH THE
PERFORMING ARTS EQUITABLE
PAYROLL FUND AS PROPOSED IN
SENATE BILL EIGHT OH FIVE FROM
SENATOR RUBIO. WHICH WILL
DIRECT CRITICAL REALLY FINDING.
STARTED SOME PRODUCTION WORKERS
CURRENTLY THE CSE PROVIDES
GRANTS ABOUT TWELVE PERCENT. OF
THE FOURTEEN THOUSAND STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT PROFIT ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS ANNUALLY. THESE
ORGANIZATIONS EMPLOY OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE AND
EARN MORE THAN SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE EACH YEAR.
FUNDING THESE ORGANIZATIONS
MEANS JOB RECOVERY AND
CREATION. ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS JUST FOR CREATIVE
WORKERS IN THE FIRST PROJECTS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
PUBLIC ARTWORKS MUSICAL AND
THEATRICAL PERFORMANCES.
COMMUNITY DOCUMENTATION
PROJECTS THAT LIFT UP THE
VOICES OF THE SYSTEMICALLY
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS AND
THAT RE FRAME AND RE IMAGINE
THE POSSIBILITIES. OF FINDING A
NEW CALIFORNIA CULTURE AND
PROVIDE TRAINING AND SUPPORT TO
NEW CREATIVE WORKERS WITH EARN
AND LEARN LIVING WAGE
OPPORTUNITIES SUCH AS PROPOSED
IN SENATOR ALLEN'S BILL
CALIFORNIA CREATED WORK FOR
SAC. SH SEE THIS IS THE RIGHT
MECHANISM AS IT. IS A LONG
ESTABLISHED COMPETITIVE
STATEWIDE GRANTS THE PROCESS
WITH THE RE IT STRICT CAMPUS ON
RAY ACT. AND FUNDING TO UNDER
REESE CONTROL MARK. COMMUNITIES
WE FOR SOME FROM USING AND
CULTURE CITY. WITH TWO HUNDRED
MILLION- TO CAL CULTURAL AND
HIS. DOWN IT RECEIVE H. E.
STATE ROUTE THAT IS. SO TWO AND
THREE IS CURRENTLY HOUSED IN.
RE AND- FUNDING FROM HIGHER
BOND IS DRIED UP AND ONLY ABOUT
HUNDRED THOUSAND A YEAR BEING.
FROM THE C. T. LYSONS PLATE
CREATED BY PROTON. LEGISLATION
TWENTY THIRTEEN. THEY NEED A
STRONG PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
BUT THE PANDEMIC HAS
STAGGERINGLY AN ADVERSE IMPACT
ON CALIFORNIA'S MUSEUMS AND
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS. FUNDING
CCH US ONE TIME DOLLARS IS
CRITICAL AND A TRANSPARENT WAY
TO DISTRIBUTE SUPPORT. MUSEUMS
AND CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
ACROSS THE STATE FROM ITS
INCEPTION CCG HAS ALWAYS
PRIORITIZED FUNDING PROJECTS
THAT UPLIFT UNDERREPRESENTED
STORIES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. LEGISLATURES A
ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES ECOSYSTEM.
AND WE HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT
THIS ITEM THANK YOU IN A
BILLABLE TO AND ANSWER ANY.
QUESTIONS REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING ONTO CASE LETTERMAN. YES
A CHECK OF A AND MEMBERS OF THE
STOCK THANK YOU FOR THE R. TO
TEST HERE TO. MY NAME IS KEITH
AMONG CO FOUNDER OF TE CAL
CHECK OF THE AND BUT SERVICE.
READ OVER HUNDRED INDEPENDENT
VENUES AND PROMOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA THESE VENUES ARE
ANCHOR TENANTS IN YOUR
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OUR VENUES
WERE THE FIRST TO CLOSE AND
WILL BE THE LAST OF FULLY
REOPENED AND WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO OUTLINE
THE IMPORTANCE OR POST GRAD
PROGRAM. I ALSO WANT TO TAKE MY
COLLEAGUE JULIE BAKER WITH
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATES FOR
HER ADVOCACY IN PARTNERSHIP.
THE FEDERAL SHUTTERS VENUE
OPERATOR GRANT PROGRAM WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE LIFELINE FOR
PROFIT AND NONPROFIT
INDEPENDENT VENUES THAT ARE NOT
MULTINATIONAL. OR PUBLICLY
TRADED COMPANIES. I WAS PASSED
AT THE OF DECEMBER BUT WELL
DONE. SO INTO. DIFFICULTY
APPLICATION DID NOT UNTIL APRIL
SIX. AND STILL NOT A DIME HAS
BEEN DISTRIBUTED. ALL THE WHILE
VENUES ARE LOSING TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH TO
REMAIN CLOSED. WE HAVE ALL THE
OVERHEAD COSTS AND ZERO REVENUE
GOING ON FOURTEEN MONTHS. EVERY
DAY WITHOUT THE FEDERAL RELIEF
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
BEEN USED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WILL CONTINUE TO SHUTTER. WHICH
IS WHY WE ARE ASKING CALIFORNIA
TO STEP IN AS SEVERAL OTHER
STATES HAVE ALREADY DONE SO. TO
PREVENT THIS CULTURAL
EXTINCTION AND ALSO MAKE SURE
THESE VENUES ARE EQUIPPED WITH
THE WORKING CAPITAL TO REOPEN.
REHIRE AND RESUME AS ANCHOR
TENANTS IN MAJOR ECONOMIC
DRIVERS OF LOCAL AND STATE
REVENUE. IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHEN IT IS SAFE TO DO USED TO
DO SO. JENNY'S GENERATE AN
ESTIMATE THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITIES
THE STATE. ADDITIONALLY THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT TO THE
STATE IS HIGH WITH THE RECENT
ECONOMIC IMPACT STUDY FINDING
THAT FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT AT
A VENUE. TWELVE DOLLARS ARE
GENERATED IN THE LOCAL ECONOMY
AT RESTAURANTS BARS LODGING
RETAIL SHOPS AND TRANSPORTATION.
IN ADDITION VENUES EMPLOYED
OVER FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND FULL
TIME JOBS INCLUDING BARTENDERS
JANITORIAL SECURITY FACILITY
MAINTENANCE PRODUCTION VENDORS
AND MORE. THE GOAL OF OUR STATE
BUDGET REQUEST IS TO TRAIN
WORKING CAPITAL THREE OPEN IN
ORDER TO MEET THE DEMANDS OF
SHUTTING DOWN FOR OVER A YEAR.
ADDRESSING NEW CODED PROTOCOLS
AND REHIRING AND RETRAINING OUR
STAFF. THE FEDERAL S. YOUR G.
PROGRAM ADDRESSES THE COLD
STORAGE OF DEBT THAT VENUES
HAVE RACKED UP SINCE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY. AND WE'RE ASKING
CALIFORNIA TO HELP US GOING
FORWARD. OUR EMPLOYEE RETENTION
IS EXPECTED TO BE ABOUT ONE
THIRD COMING OUT OF THIS KIND
OF MAKE. THE REMAINING TWO
THIRDS WILL BE JOB CREATION IN
REPLACEMENT. MEANING AN
ESTIMATED TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY
THOUSAND NEW HIRES IN A REAL
PAIN PROCESS. EVEN IF VENUES
WERE ABLE TO OPEN TOMORROW WE
WOULD NOT SEE REVENUE FOR MANY
MORE MONTHS IS BOOKING TALENT
DEPENDS ON A NATIONAL TOURING
ECOSYSTEM. RELY ON EVERY STATE
BEING OPEN. ONE STYLE IS BOOKED
IT TAKES THREE TO SIX MONTHS TO
MARKET THE SHOW SELL TICKETS
HIGHER STATS AND PRODUCED A
CONCERT. HALL CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF MEASURES TO
DATE WERE APPRECIATED. TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR GRANTS
CANNOT STEM THE LOSSES FOR A
MAJORITY OF VENUES. AND THE
STATE PROGRAM OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS IS LIMITED TO NON
PROFITS. THAT'S A LIMITING
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE WHITE
MAJORITY. OF VENUES AND
PROMOTERS IN CALIFORNIA. PLEASE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE I DON'T
THE CREW NEED TO. IN VENUES
DURING THE SPEND I CAN READ-
AND FOR EXAMPLE. IT'S MILLION
DOLLAR PER AND THEN IN
ALLOCATION THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR AN ESTIMATED ONE
HUNDRED VENUES. THESE GREAT
AMOUNTS PER INCH TV IN OTHER
STATE PROPOSALS ARE IN LINE OR
GREATER THAN WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING FOR CALIFORNIA. OF
ALL THE STATES CALIFORNIA HAS
THE MOST VENUES AND THE MOST
JOBS AT STAKE. CALIFORNIA IS
NOT ONLY THE BURST BIRTHPLACE
OF THE MODERN CONCERT INDUSTRY
BUT ALSO HAS SOME OF THE MOST
ICONIC INDEPENDENT VENUES IN
THE COUNTRY. WELL ON THE WORLD
RECOGNIZING THEIR VALUE TO THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
IMPACT WITH THE STIMULUS GRANT
PROGRAM WOULD BE A STATEMENT
FOR COMMUNITIES AND THE REST OF
THE NATION. IN CLOSING I WANT
TO REFER TO AN ARTICLE IN
VARIETY THAT WAS PUBLISHED LAST
WEEK. THE ARTICLE EXPLAINED HOW
TO PROLONG DELAYS OF OUR
LIFELINE IN THE S. B. O. G.
PROGRAM WE'RE SENSUALLY
EXACERBATING THE CREATION OF A
MORE OF A MONOPOLY IN THE LIVE
MUSIC AND PERFORMANCE INDUSTRY.
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED VENUES
SMALL BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA
I'VE HAD TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS
WITH ZERO SUPPORT WHILE LARGER
ENTITIES ARE ABLE TO WITHSTAND
WITHSTAND ECONOMIC IMPACT WITH
SHAREHOLDERS. TELEVISION
BROADCAST AND SPONSORSHIP
FUNDING. LASTLY THE NET OF
INDEPENDENT VENUES IS BROAD
JUST ASK THE RESTAURANT OWNER
WHO WILL TELL YOU HOW HE
STARTED HIS BUSINESS NEAR VENUE
DUE TO THE CONSISTENT DRIVE
CUSTOMERS. WHO NOW FACES AN
UNCERTAIN FUTURE WITH THE VENUE
SHUTTERED AND CROWDS OF PEOPLE
DIMINISHED OR ASK THE ARTISTS
TOMORROW'S RED HOT CHILLI
PEPPERS ARE TRUE FIGHTERS. NO
LONGER HAVE THE STAGE TO
PERFORM AT TO REFINE THEIR
CRAFT OR TO GROW THEIR
AUDIENCE. THESE VENUES ARE
CRITICAL PIECES OF CALIFORNIA'S
CULTURE AND ECONOMY AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND
I AM AVAILABLE AS WELL
TRANSGRESSIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY GOING
TO SEE IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS ANY COMMENT.
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HOW
ABOUT- GOBIZ. NO COMMENT FROM
GLOBUS. OUR CENTER NO COMMENT
FROM COLUMBUS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I'LL BRING AT
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
DIETS AND SENATOR NELSON. THIS
IS A BILLION DOLLARS. IT LOOKS
LIKE IT FLOWS THROUGH THEN
EQUALLY DISTRIBUTED THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY ACCESS TO ARCH. AND
THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE I
GATHER SOMEONE ASKED ME
SPECIFICALLY BUT THE THROUGH
THE ARTS COUNCIL FOR THEIR
DIFFERENT SPELLING THAT
DOUBLING UP THOSE GRAPHS. END
OF THE WORKFORCE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT FUNDING AND
MEASUREMENTS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTION TO SET THE REALM OF.
ENTITIES FOR THE MONEY WILL
FLOW. US SENATOR NELSON THIS IS
JULIE BAKER YES- AT THEIR
COMMUNITY ACCESS TO THE ARTS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL OVER
THE NEXT TWO TO FOUR YEARS
INVESTMENTS SO THAT THESE
ORGANIZATIONS CAN ALSO BUILD
BACK ORGANIZATIONAL
SUSTAINABILITY. AND THEY GET
CREATIVE WORKFORCE ACT RIGHT
NOW ALSO IS LOOKING TO GO
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL WITH- THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN
COLLABORATION AND THEN THE
MUSICIANS WOULD GO THROUGH- C.
C. H. E. UNDER THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY WHICH HAS NOT.
BEEN OUT OF FOR AN AGENCY THAT
HAS JUST BEEN. UNDER FUNDED FOR
MANY MANY YEARS. THAT'S QUITE A
QUITE A NUMBER FOR THE OUT CAN
FOR YOU THEY WHOLE BY WAS ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THAT THAT
THIS IS- IT'LL BE A BIG. BOOST
I SEE MERIT IN IT THAT WE WILL
NEED TO TAKE A TAKE A DEEPER
LOOK AT. THANK IT'S A POINT
WELL TAKEN. SENATOR I THINK I
HAVE THAT. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I LIKE THIS PROPOSAL- THE
QUESTION IS ONE OF CAPACITY AND
MARKET CAPACITY IN TERMS OF-
THE ABILITY TO MOVE MONEY OUT
AND MAKE SURE IT'S- EVENLY
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE-
THROUGHOUT THE- THE STATE AND-
A LONG BEEN CONCERNED THAT. A
LOT OF THE TIMES THE ARTS MONEY
TENDS TO GO TOWARDS
COMMUNITIES- THAT HAVE THE
ECONOMIC RESOURCES TO- TO FIND
LOCAL PROGRAMS AND IT DOESN'T
GO TO THOSE COMMUNITIES MANY OF
WHOM I REPRESENT THAT BOMBS.
WERE EQUITY IS A BIG ISSUE SO
I- THIS IS A HOLD UP AN ITEM I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT- I
APPRECIATE THAT. THE- THE NEED
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ECONOMIC. INVESTMENT THIS WOULD
BE A NO QUESTION ABOUT THE FACT
THAT- BUT IT'S- THAT WE NEED TO
GET THE- CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS-
OPEN AND OPERATING AGAIN IN
ORDER FOR US TO- TO REALLY
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY I THINK
PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS FOR THIS
KIND OF RIGHT THEY THEY'RE
ANXIOUS FOR THEM TO OPEN AND SO
ANYWAY WE CAN HELP WITH IT
WOULD BE GOOD. BUT I ALSO SHARE
THE CONCERNS THE CENTER NIELSEN
HAS IN TERMS OF THE CAPACITY
AND THE ABILITY TO MOVE OUT THE
RESOURCES QUICKLY. SO THIS IS A
HOLDOVER HOLD OPEN ITEMS WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY
WHICH IS THE- TOURISM RECOVERY
CAMPAIGN. WILL AGAIN TURN THE-
THE ISSUE OVER TO MISTER
WEATHERFORD FOODS- IS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY IS
THE SENATE'S BUDGET PLAN FOR
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING TO VISIT
CALIFORNIA THESE FUNDS WOULD BE
USED TO SUPPORT A LOCAL
REGIONAL AND NATIONAL MARKETING
CAMPAIGN ENCOURAGING TRAVEL TO
AND WITHIN CALIFORNIA. VERY
GOOD- NEXT LIKE TO ASK- MELIA.
THE MONEY TO- WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
AND PUBLIC POLICY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
TO PRESENT. MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK CLASS THE
CHAIR SAID MY NAME IS AND
MILLIONS OF MONEY I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA IN.
ASSOCIATION WHERE THE ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING THE
TRAVEL AND TOURISM INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
REQUEST FOR A FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
ALLOCATION TO FUND THE TOURISM
MARKETING CAMPAIGN. PRODUCED BY
THIS A CALIFORNIA%
RECOVER THE STATE'S TOURISM
ECONOMY. HOW TRAVELERS WERE
MARGINALLY ENOUGH FAMILIAR
LEGALLY NO ENGAGES WITH A
LETTER. AND ADMINISTRATION
PROTECT AND ENSURE A THRIVING
TRAVEL AND TOURISM INDUSTRY WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH BUT ARE
DISTINCT FROM ITS A CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA IS A
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT FROM NEARLY
THIRTY YEARS AGO TO MARKET
CALIFORNIA TRAVELERS. THE
MARKETING IS FINANCED BY
ASSESSMENTS ON MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND BUSINESSES BASED ON
THE PORTION OF INCOME THAT
COMES FROM TRAVELERS. TO THE
PANDEMIC VISIT CALIFORNIA'S
BUDGET WITH A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. BUT BECAUSE THEY ARE
FUNDED ON TOURISM BUSINESSES
REVENUE. WHEN TRAVEL STOPPED SO
DID THEIR FUNDING. IS A
CALIFORNIA CONCERT CASH FOR
RECOVERY CAMPAIGN BUT THEIR
MARKETING WILL STOP IN JUNE OF
THIS YEAR AS RESOURCES DWINDLE.
CODE HAS BEEN ESPECIALLY UNKIND
TO CALIFORNIA. TOURISM BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA WAS THE
COUNTRY'S TOP TOURISM ECONOMY
IT'S NOW AMONG THE WORST
PERFORMING ONLY FIVE STATES
HAVE LOST MORE VISITOR SPENDING
SINCE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY.
CALIFORNIA LOST 2626% OF ITS
MARKET SHARE TO OTHER STATES
AND TWENTY TWENTY. FLORIDA AND
TEXAS BOTH GREW THEIR MARKET
SHARE LAST YER. ALARMINGLY IN
THE CAPITAL FLORIDA OUR BIGGEST
TOURISM COMPETITOR WAS RECENTLY
ALLOCATED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THEIR STATE'S%
BUDGET. TO MARKET THE STATE
TRAVELERS INCLUDING TARGETING
CALIFORNIANS. THIS PUTS US AT
AN EVEN MORE OF A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE FLORIDA
HAS BEEN OPEN FOR BUSINESS FOR
MUCH OF THE PANDEMIC. HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING AWAY OUR
VISITORS AND OUR RESIDENTS. SIX
LOSSES ESPECIALLY CRITICAL
BECAUSE TAXES PAID BY HOTEL AND
VACATION RENTAL GUESTS DIRECTLY
POWER LOCAL COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. FORTY SIX CITIES
RELY ON TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY TAX
REVENUE. TO COVER AT LEAST 30%
OF THEIR OVERALL GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE. SHARES FOR THE
LOSSES MEAN LOSSES JUST. THIRTY
BUCKS. GETTING CALIFORNIA'S
TRAVELING AGAIN WILL ENABLE OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES TO HELP AND
GET WORKERS BACK TO THEIR JOBS.
AND ULTIMATELY HELP THE ECONOMY
RECOVER FROM KOBE. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES THE.
FOR NINE ELEVEN AND I'LL KEEP
SHORT TO DRIVE AN INCREMENTAL
THREE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. A VISITOR SPENDING
GENERATED TEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN DIRECT STATE TAX
REVENUE THAT MORE THAN REPAID
THE STATES ONE TIME BEST MAN.
IN STATE TRAVEL JUMPED 10% IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE. TWO THOUSAND
TWO AND TOURISM WAS ONE OF THE
FASTEST INDUSTRIES TO RECOVER.
IT GIVEN THE ALLOCATION UNDER
CONSIDERATION TODAY IT IS
ANTICIPATED THAT WAS A
CALIFORNIA CAN GENERATE TEN
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUE. CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
AND EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE MILLION IN ADDITIONAL
STATE AND LOCAL TAX REVENUE.
FOR THESE REASONS WE URGE OUR
SUPPORT INCLUDING THIS CRITICAL
ONE TIME FINDING DEPICTS A
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY- MOVE ON TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
TAMARA JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NO COMMENTS. VERY GOOD-
BRING IT BACK TO THE DIETS
SENATOR NELSON ANY QUESTIONS ON
THIS ONE. NOTE SAYING NOPE NO
QUESTIONS ON I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS EITHER THIS IS A
HOLDOVER OPEN ITEM SO WE WILL
DO THAT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY I WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY
ONE WHICH IS WORKER OWNERSHIP
TRANSITION SUPPORT- AND AGAIN-
BRIAN WEATHERFORD. WE'RE
KEEPING YOU BUSY TODAY. THANK
YOU YES- ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY ONE
IS THE SENATE'S BUDGET PLAN TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA WORKER
OWNED SMALL BUSINESS CREDIT
SUPPORT AND GRANT INCENTIVES
FUND WITH THIRTY SIX POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING. AS DESCRIBED IN THE
AGENDA THIS NEW PROGRAM WOULD
SUPPORT TRANSITIONS TO WORKER
OWNERSHIP BUSINESS MODELS
FUNDING COULD BE ALLOCATED FOR
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION LOAN
GUARANTEES THROUGH A BANK
GRANTS TO COVER CONVERSION
COSTS SUCH AS FEASIBILITY
STUDIES TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT COSTS.
AND I WE HAVE NO OTHER-
COMMENTS ON THIS THIS ISSUE.
OKAY I'D LIKE TO- CAN INVITE A
JUSTIN ROSE ROSE ST. JEEZ. WHO
IS- THE CONTRACT LOBBYISTS FOR
THE WORKER OWNED RECOVERY
CALIFORNIA COALITION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- CREATE
THE INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY
MY NAME IS JUSTIN RAZA. AND
REPRESENTING THE WORKERS ON A
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA COALITION
WORKS MISSION IS TO ADVANCE AND
PROTECT WORKER COOPERATIVES AND
OTHER EMPLOYEE OWNED MANAGED
AND GOVERNED WORKPLACES IN
CALIFORNIA YOUR ADVOCACY
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION. WE ARE
A COALITION OF STATE AND
NATIONAL EXPERTS ON WORKER
OWNERSHIP WORKER OWNED BUSINESS
AND ORGANIZED LABOR. I'LL BE ON
STANDBY FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND REQUESTED SO LOW WHEN IT
WORKS COALITION MEMBERS WILL
PRESENT HIS BUDGET PROPOSAL ON
THE REMAINING TIME THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH I'D
LIKE TO INVITE RAY CHRISS
TELLO. WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH AND SEE A
U. U. H. W. WEST TO PLEASE
PRESENT. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RAY KRISTA
TULLOW I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF RESEARCH AT STI U. U. H. W.
WEST. OR A LABOR UNION OF
NEARLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
SEIU USW MEMBERS ARE FRONT LINE
CARE GIVERS INCLUDING
RESPIRATORY CARE PRACTITIONERS
DIETARY ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES
AND NURSING STAFF WHO AIM TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
BY PROVIDING QUALITY CARE FOR
ALL PATIENTS EXPANDING ACCESS
TO EXCELLENT AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND IMPROVING LIVING STANDARDS
FOR ALL WORKERS. AS A MEMBER OF
THE WORK COALITION WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDERING SENATOR BACKERS
BUDGET REQUESTS TODAY REGARDING
HOW WORKER OWNERSHIP CAN CREATE
A MORE EQUITABLE ECONOMY.
ESPECIALLY FOR UNDERPAID
WORKERS WORKERS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES FACE A DOOR CRISIS A
COVERT NINETEEN INDUCED
ECONOMIC SHUT DOWN AS WELL AS
THE PRE XISTING WAVE OF
BUSINESS CLOSURES DUE TO THE
SILVER TSUNAMI OR BABY BOOMER
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE AT OR
NEAR RETIREMENT AGE. EVEN
BEFORE COATED THERE WERE OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
BUSINESSES AT RISK OF CLOSURE
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEIR
OWNERS ARE OLDER AND DON'T HAVE
A SUCCESSION PLAN. RATHER THAN
CLOSING FOR GOOD OR SELLING TO
LARGE OUT OF STATE BUYERS
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS CAN FIND WILLING BUYERS
IN THE PEOPLE WHO WORK
ALONGSIDE THEM EVERY DAY. THEIR
WORKERS. TRANSITIONING TO
WORKER OWNERSHIP WILL ANCHOR
ESSENTIAL PRODUCTION SERVICES
IN COMMUNITIES SAVE LIVELIHOODS
OVER AT LAYOFFS BUILD WEALTH
FOR CALIFORNIANS AND SAVE THE
STATE MONEY. I'M FULLY OWNED
BUSINESSES HAVE PROVEN
THEMSELVES TO BE MORE RESILIENT
AND MORE FOUR TIMES LESS LIKELY
TO LAY PEOPLE OFF DURING THE
PANDEMIC. MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
STUDIES SHOW THAT WORKER
OWNERSHIP IS GOOD FOR BUSINESS
IS. GOOD FOR JOBS AND GOOD FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IT'S TRULY A
WIN WIN WIN. GOVERNMENT SUPPORT
FOR WORKER OWNERSHIP ISN'T
NOVEL THE FEDERAL MAINSTREAM
PLAY OWNERSHIP ACT WAS ENACTED
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MANDATING
THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT WORKER
OWNERSHIP PROMPTING NEW AND
CONTINUED SUPPORT IN A NUMBER
OF STATES INCLUDING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR BUDGET RECOMMENDATIONS WILL
CATALYZE INCLUSIONARY AND
EQUITABLE CHANGES IN THE
ECONOMY WITHOUT REINVENTING THE
WHEEL AND BY DEDICATING
RESOURCES TOWARDS CONVERSIONS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES. ONE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING WOULD BE USED TO
IMPLEMENT A THREE YEAR
STATEWIDE OUTREACH PROGRAM
ABOUT WORKER OWNERSHIP. THIS
CAMPAIGN WILL FOCUS ON THE
VALUE OF WORKER OWNERSHIP AND
SMALL BUSINESS RETENTION LAYOFF
AVERSION AND COMMUNITY WEALTH
BUILDING. AS WELL AS FINANCING
OPTIONS TO SUPPORT THESE
TRANSITIONS. TWENTY FOUR AND A
HALF MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDING TO CREATE A DEDICATED
LOAN GUARANTEE PROGRAM AT I.
BANK. TO FINANCE BUSINESS
CONVERSIONS QUALIFIED WORKER
OWNERSHIP MODELS. WHEN A LOAN
UNDER THESE LOAN GUARANTEE
PROGRAMS FOR CHORES OF FUNDS IN
THE LOAN GUARANTEE RESERVE CAN
BE RELEASED BACK INTO THE
DEDICATED POOL. TO SUPPORT MORE
SMALL BUSINESS CONVERSIONS AND
ENGAGEMENT CAPITAL PROVIDERS.
THREE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
INCENTIVE GRANTS TO BUSINESSES
THAT MEET SPECIFIED CONDITIONS
FOR WORKER OWNERSHIP
CONVERSIONS. AND THREE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE
TIME FUNDING WOULD FUND
TARGETED BUSINESS OUTREACH
EFFORTS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND PROFESSIONAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS. BUSINESS NETWORKS
AND OTHER TRUSTED ADVISORS IN
THE FIELD OF WORKER OWNERSHIP.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND SENATOR
BACKERS AND SENATOR WIENER'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE ALONG
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CALL
RIGHT TO GOOD SOLID. ROBERT
READ LAST FILL UP A DOULA AND
WICKS WHO SUBMITTED THE SAME
REQUEST IN THE OTHER HOUSE. AND
JUSTIN AND I ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION PRECIADO
VERY MUCH. I'M JUST AND I'M AND
I'M ASSUMING THAT- THAT THAT
CONCLUDES YOUR TESTIMONY AS
WELL. S. MANAGER OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. TAMARA JOHNSON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- GLOBUS ANY
COMMENTS. NO COMMENTS FROM THE
ABYSS A GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE DYESS AT NO QUESTIONS
FROM SENT THERE SENATOR- I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AS
WELL- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS IS A- HOLD OPEN ITEM AND I
EXPECT WE'RE GOING TO SEE IT
BACK SO I THINK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY
IT'S BEEN VERY INSTRUCTIVE. AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE LAST
HEARING ITEM WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTY TWO WHICH IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ENTERPRISE
DATED TO REVENUE PROJECT PHASE
TWO. AND I'D LIKE TO INVITE-
THE- CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX TAX
BOARD JEANNIE HERMAN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HOPE YOU'RE ALL DOING
WELL J. I WILL BE PRESENTING
THE BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL AND
THE SPRING FINANCE LETTER
SUPPORTING THE ENTERPRISE DATA
TO REVENUE BASED JAIL OR
COMMONLY KNOWN AS U. D. R. TWO.
THANK YOU FOR THE AGENDA RIGHT
UP THE PROVIDES INFORMATION ON
THE GOALS OF THE STATUS OF THE
PROJECT. PETER TO PROJECT IS
SCHEDULED TO BEGIN JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WITH FINAL
APPROVAL RECEIVED ON STAGE GATE
OR- FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY ON
APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND THE AWARDING OF THE
CONTRACT IN JANET TWENTY TWENTY
ONE A FEW SHORT WEEKS FROM NOW.
BASED ON THE STATUS OF THE
PROJECT IN THE LATTER PART OF
TWENTY TWENTY FTP PRESENTED A
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL WITH
ESTIMATED RESOURCES THAT WOULD
BE NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE ET RG
PROJECT FOR ITS FIRST YEAR.
THESE RESOURCES REPRESENTATIVE
IN JANUARY BUDGET AND INCLUDED
FIFTY FIVE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING. ASSOCIATED
WITH TWENTY THREE PERMANENT OR
PERMANENT INTERMITTENT
POSITIONS AND THIRTEEN LIMITED
TERM POSITION. NOW THAT THE
PROCUREMENT PHASE HAS WRAPPED
UP THE SPRING FINANCE LETTER%
RECONCILES ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES NEEDED. FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO OF THOSE
PREVIOUSLY REQUESTED. A SPRING
FINANCE LETTER BEING PRESENTED
NOW REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION
IN FUNDING. INCLUDING ONE
FUNDING INCLUDING MONEY FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL PERMANENT POSITION.
THE PRIMARY FUNDING INCREASE
NOTED AND THE STRING FINANCED
LETTER PROPOSAL IS TO COVER THE
EXPECTED BENDER COMPENSATION
COSTS. THESE RESOURCES ARE
CLUSTERED IN THE STRING FINANCE
THAT ARE ARE IN ADDITION TO
THOSE REQUESTED IN THE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AFTER BEING
PARKED ON A PROJECT A THIRTY
YEAR JOURNEY TO UPDATE OUR TAX
SYSTEMS. ENGINEER TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE COMPLETED THE FIRST
OF THREE STAGES THAT MUST
JOURNEY WITH ALL
IMPLEMENTATIONS OF DELIVERABLES
UNDER THE EDR PROJECT. THAT
EFFORT LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR
CENTRALIZING TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS SUPPORTING KEY
BUSINESS FUNCTIONS. NOW WE'RE
READY FOR ANY OR TWO WHICH
BUILT ON THIS PLATFORM BY
EXPANDING ENTERPRISE CASE
MANAGEMENT AND MODELING SERVICE
FOR AUDIT BY WOMEN FOR SPRINTS
AND COUNT RECEIVABLE FUNCTIONS
AS WELL AS EXPANDING ON VERY
IMPORTANT CUSTOMER SERVICE
TOOLS INCLUDING THE TAXPAYER
FOLDER. COMMONLY KNOWN AS MY
FTP. AS WELL AS BUILDING ON THE
BUILDING BLOCKS ESTABLISHED AN
EDR EDR TOO WILL ALSO ENSURE
THAT HAVE TO BE AS ABLE TO
REPLACE CRITICAL COMPLIANCE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE PENDING AND
THE PLIGHT. I HAVE TO BE RELIES
ON THESE COMPLIANCE SYSTEMS TO
SUPPORT GENERATION OF REVENUE
OVER FOUR BILLION ANNUALLY.
BOTH THE B. C. PM SPRING
FINANCE LETTERING COULD
RESOURCES ONLY FOR THE FIRST
YEAR THE PROJECT ARE NOTED IS
EITHER ONGOING. OR LIMITED TERM
WITHIN THE BODY OF THE REQUEST.
THESE RESOURCES REQUESTED WILL
ENSURE THE FTP HAS THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF RESOURCES
FOR SUCCESSFUL FIRST YEAR THE
PROJECT. THIS TIME I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANKYOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. SEE
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAS ANY COMMENTS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIRTY SEVENS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE F. F. T. F. T.
PEACE PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. HELLO BRAND
WHETHER FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
ARE DETAILED COMMENTS ON THIS
ITEM ARE INCLUDED IN THE AGENDA
SO JUST BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE OUR
MAIN POINTS. THE FIRST COMMENT
IS IN REGARDS TO STAFFING FTV
HAS DEVELOPED A DETAILED
PROJECT MANAGEMENT STAFFING
PLAN THAT FOLLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
GUIDANCE AND INTEGRATES LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE FIRST YEAR
PROJECT WE FIND. THAT WITHIN
THESE PROPOSALS STAFFING
REQUESTS HAVE REASONABLE
JUSTIFICATION. ON OUR SECOND
COMMENTS IN REGARD TO THE
REQUESTED- PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT ON THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED THE BENEFITS AND
PERFORMANCE SPACE STRUCTURE THE
VENDOR COMPENSATION MODEL
REQUIRE SOME ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY. AND WHICH THIS
PROPOSED LANGUAGE WOULD ALLOW
HOWEVER WE ALSO WOULD NOTE THAT
A PORTION OF THE TRADITIONAL
LANGUAGE THAT WAS PROPOSED IN
THE JANUARY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WOULD ALLOW THE HAVE TO BE TO
REQUEST ADDITIONAL CONTINGENCY
FUNDS OUTSIDE OF THE STANDARD
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCES. AND THAT
SEEMS- DOUBLING WHICH SEEMS
UNNECESSARY HOWEVER THAT SAID
THIS LANGUAGE WOULD ALLOW THE
US TO BE INCREASED FLEXIBILITY
TO RESPOND TO THE URGENT
UNEXPECTED CONTINGENCIES. AND
THEN I CAN OUR REMARKS GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GONNA
BRING THE QUESTIONS BACK TO THE
DIETS SENATOR NELSON THE
QUESTIONS SAYING NONE- SENATOR
CATALOGUER WORK WE'RE ON ITEM.
NUMBER. FIFTY TO. IT'S A NO
QUESTIONS ON THE ONLY COMMENT I
HAVE IS JUST- DEAD DEAD I JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND SALUTE
FTV FURTHER- THEIR PRIDE THEIR
IT PROJECTS HAVE BEEN EXEMPLARY
AND- IT DID IT THE ATTENTION TO
DETAIL THE TENSION TO THE
CONTRACT DETAILS AND- TO
MEETING THAT THE GOALS OF THE
PROJECT AS WELL AS THE TIME
LINE IS- HAS ALWAYS BEEN-
STELLAR AND SO. I DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM AND- AND WHAT'S
MOST IMPORTANT I THINK ABOUT
THE TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS EVEN
SUCCESSFUL IN BRINGING ONLINE
IS THAT YOU'VE INCREASED
REVENUE BECAUSE OF THE ABILITY
TO- UTILIZE TECHNOLOGY TO GET
BETTER RESULTS IN SOME
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT AND-
THIS IS AN ITEM. THAT WE WILL
TAKE. ACTION ON THIS THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE AS
BUDGETED- WE STILL NEED TO GO
THROUGH THE HEARING PROCESS SO
WE'LL BE TAKING THIS UP AT A
LATER TIME SEEING NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS WILL MOVE ON. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON JUST YOU TWO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
COMPLIMENTS- FTV CHILI
RECOGNIZES IT AS AN ABSOLUTE.
NEED FOR THE VILLAGE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET DONE WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO GET DONE- FROM
OUR EXTERNAL PARTNERS TWO YEAR
JAIL ARE VENDORS THAT WE
PARTNER WITH DOWNHILL- OUR
STAFF. THAT IMPLEMENT AND
CALIFORNIANS SO IT'S VERY MUCH
A GROUP EFFORT AND WE'RE VERY
EXCITED FOR THIS PROJECT. VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY.
SO WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FOR THE PUBLIC
TO COMMENT. REGARDING ANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE DISCUSSED
TODAY. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT ONE EIGHT. TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN. DO DO DO DO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC PROVIDING TESTIMONY KEEP
THEIR REMARKS. TO WITHIN ONE
MINUTE. NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THERE IS ONE
WITNESS YOU MAY PROCEED. YOUR
COVER YOUR OWN MEMBERS ALEX
TAURUS WAS STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND-
INDICATE OUR SUPPORT ONCE AGAIN
FOR ITEM NUMBER FORTY FORTY
NINE. POINT OF CLARIFICATION
THE INDEPENDENT VENUES PROGRAM
WHICH IS PART OF THIS ONE
BILLION DOLLAR ARTS PROPOSAL
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WOULD BE HOUSED WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE AND THE
GRANTS WOULD BE ADMINISTERED
THAT WAY- SO JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT. AS AN INDUSTRY
THIS IS AN INDUSTRY THAT NEVER
HAD TO ADVOCATE BEFORE THEY'VE
BEEN- ANCHOR TENANTS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND IF IT'S TOTALLY
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR LOCAL AND
STATE REVENUES. AND NOW THEY'RE
COMING TO THE LEGISLATORS
LEGISLATURE AT A TIME WHEN IT
IS ACTUALLY CRITICAL VENUES
ACROSS THE NATION ARE
SHUTTERING BUT THEN HE'S IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO FACE THE
RISK AS WE FOLLOW SCIENCE AND
FOLLOW THE PUBLIC SAFETY
GUIDELINES BUT- WE GET WE HAVE
NOT OFFERED SUPPORT FEES VENUES
SO. I ALSO WANT TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR VENUES THROUGHOUT
THE CITY CALIFORNIA YOU DO NOT
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CALL IN
TODAY. AND THEN THIS RANDOM
SAMPLING OF CALIFORNIA VENUES I
THINK YOU'LL SEE THE GEOGRAPHIC
DIVERSITY REGION OR A YOU KNOW
A RURAL URBAN SUBURBAN.
EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA THEIR
VENUES ALL THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PROPOSAL WE HAVE THE
BROADWAY THEATER GROUP IN LOS
ANGELES CONCERT CONSISTING OF
FOUR. VENUES THEMSELVES TO DO
THE DOUGH LAB PROMOTER OF
LIGHTNING IN A BOTTLE IN KERN
COUNTY THE FESTIVAL STEPHEN
ACOSTA THE OWNER OF THE
SILVERLAKE LOUNGE IN LOS
ANGELES COMPLEX OAKLAND IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA JIM CORNETTE
THE OWNER OF HARLOW'S HERE IN
SACRAMENTO JUST DOWN TO J.
STREET- IN- YOUR DISTRICT
SENATOR NIELSEN THE SENATOR
THEATRE. IN CHICO- PREP HELL
OWNERS HAVE. TO LAWSON NEAR.
AND KAMEL. AND I UNDERSTAND ALL.
OF USE TO THE STATE WILL ALSO
BE CALLING INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT AS WELL ONCE AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING OUT THE
DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL. OF THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION BUT
ALSO THE BROADER INVESTMENT IS
TRANSFORMATIVE INVESTMENT IN
ARTS- LOOK FOR DISCUSSING WITH
YOU ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY PRECIADO THE
INFORMATION- IT IS SO SAYING NO
FURTHER. TESTIMONY HERE IN THIS
HEARING ROOM WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ROOM AT TWENTY FORTY.
AND THAT IS AS USUAL VERY.
EMPTY SO WE'LL WE'RE WE'RE NOW-
I'M GOING TO MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES THAT ARE WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO PROVIDE CLUB PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL BEGIN. AND LADIES
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SHARE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE YOU MAY REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM QUEUE AT ANY TIME BY
PRESSING ONE ZERO AGAIN. IF
USING A SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS ONCE AGAIN
YOU HAVE A QUESTION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'LL START WITH ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FOUR AND GERMAN PERSCRIPTION
RESPONSIBLE. ALREADY ON BEHALF
COALITION AIR CARGO ONE SECOND
JUSTICE RECONSTRUCTED QUARTERLY
ISSUE FOR YOU BOB SUPPORT. FOR
BOTH LAW I. KNOW ANY OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MR. ASIAN
OTHER NOMINEES SHOULD RUN IF
YOU ARE A NEW RIGHT EVERYWHERE
PROBLEM. THE MAIN SOURCE OF THE
HOW ARE RARELY MENTION I'M SURE
SHOULD AS A STARTING POINT- BOX
MORE YOU KNOW HER THE YEAR AT
ALL I'M STILL BRITAIN MORTAR
BUSINESSES- IT IS THAT THE
FUNDS OCTOBER. INCLUSION RIDERS
TO HAVE A FULL RECOVERY FOR THE
STATE ALL WE DO. WORK TO OUR
CHILDREN. WITH THE ISSUE- THANK
YOU VERY. NEXT PLEASE. BACK
WE'VE GOT A LINE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MACK BROWN ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAMSTERS ARE MEMBERS IN
THAT HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY
URGING YOUR SUPPORT PRIDE IN IT
EIGHT YEAH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT PLEASE. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MR VICE CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF COMMENTS HI
THIS IS JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS WITH
RESPECT TO ITEM FORTY NINE AND
YOUR SUPPORT OF COMMONS INDEED
WERE ABOUT THE ARTS CULTURE AND
CREATIVE ECONOMY PROPOSAL I
JUST WANTED TO FLAG THAT
CALIFORNIANS MUSEUMS AND
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS LOST AN
ESTIMATED TWENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS PER DAY. DURING THE
MORE THAN A YEAR THAT THEY WERE
COMPLETELY CLOSED THIS LAST
YEAR- AND SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE CONSIDERATION OF THIS
PROPOSAL I'D ALSO LIKE TO JUST
MENTION RELATIVE TO A COMMENT
IN THE AGENDA THAT THE
SHUTTERED VENUE OPERATING GRANT
PROGRAM- WHILE SOME MUSEUMS ARE
ELIGIBLE THOSE WITH SIX EATING
AND REGULAR LIFE PROGRAMMING
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT
PROGRAM- THAT WOULD LEAVE A
HIGH ENOUGH MAHLER.
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
IN ELIGIBLE FOR THAT PROGRAM SO
I JUST WANTED TO FLAG THAT J.
UNDERSCORE THE NEED FOR INDIAN
INVESTMENTS AND THEN FINALLY
INTO YOUR YOUR COMMENT MR VICE
CHAIR WE HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN THE C. C. H. C.
TEAM TO HANDLE AND FRANKLY THAT
ARE CANCELED TEAM TO HANDLE-
MOVING THE ACCOUNT TO FIND OVER
THREE TO FOUR YEAR TIME HORIZON
THAT WE'VE PROPOSED. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. CONNECT TO THE LINE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID NELSON
HERE CALLING FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE REGARDING
ITEM NUMBER FORTY EIGHT OUT OF
MICROBICIDES RELIEF I NEED- WE
ARE FIRMLY COMMITTED AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT- IT THE SENATE
BUDGET PLAN TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES. WE
WERE- A PART OF THE TAPE
NETWORK THAT TELL A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT EXPANSION PROGRAM
NETWORK THAT HELPED THE FIRST
PAGES OF THE CALIFORNIA REALLY
GRANT GO OUT THE DOOR AND THERE
WERE SOME SIGNIFICANT LESSONS
LEARNED AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH. YOU ALL IN THE
COMMITTEE- IN GOING BASED ON
STAFF'S COMMENT WHICH WE AGREE
THAT THERE COULD BE SOME MORE
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO EXPEDITE-
FUND ALLOCATION. TO MICRO AND
SMALL BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT ARE MINORITY OR
LITTLE AREA. IT CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET THE PRODUCT
OUT IN A QUICK AND EXPEDITED
FASHION BOX TO PRESERVING DATA
INTEGRITY SO THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF OUR OF OUR
COMMENTS AND YOU SUPPORT. THE
ITEM IN THE BUDGET THANK YOU.
PLEASE GET YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS
INTO THE BUDGET- STAFF WE'D
APPRECIATE ANY INSIGHTS YOU
HAVE. MUCH APPRECIATED NEXT
PLEASE. YES A LITTLE LINE FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KIRK HARKIN CALLING ON
ON BEHALF OF A SLICE OF NEW
YORK A WORKER COOPERATIVE IT'S
A SHOP IN SANTA CLARA AND
SUNNYVALE CALIFORNIA AND WE
SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY ONE
ON TODAY'S AGENDA THAT WILL
PROMOTE CONVERGENCE OF SMALL
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA TO
WORKER OWNERSHIP. AS A BUSINESS
PREVENTION LAYOFF AVERSION AND
WEALTH BUILDING STRATEGY THE
DEDICATED STATEWIDE OUTREACH
AND EDUCATION CAMPAIGN CAPITAL
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ARE
INTEGRAL TO BUILDING MRE
INCLUSIVE AND RESILIENT ECONOMY
NOT ONLY DO THE PANDEMIC BUT
ALSO BECAUSE OF THE AGING
POPULATION KNOWN AS THE SILVER
SCREEN ON. THE STAGE TO SUPPORT
THIS POWERFUL MDEL THAT
BENEFITS BOTH WORKERS AND
BUSINESSES ACROSS ALL SECTORS
OF OUR ECONOMY. SANTA CLARA
COUNTY'S FIRST BRICK AND MORTAR
WORKER COOPERATIVES WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE OTHER BUSINESSES IN
OUR AREA TO LEARNING CONSIDER
THIS BUSINESS MODEL LIKE I DID
BACK. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. IN MEXICO LINE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON JAMIE MINOR HOCKEY AT
THE BLOCKCHAIN ADD THE
COALITION- MITTENS ON ITEM OR
ISSUE FORTY FIVE ON THE DIGITAL
ID- WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF PDP'S
GOAL CREATING A MORE SEAMLESS
IDENTITY FIT THEM FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THE
ACTIVE DIRECTED HOWEVER A WE DO
SHARE THE L. A. L. A. L. DURING
THE BOUT DATA SECURITY AND
PRIVACY RISKS AND THAT CREATING
A SINGLE UNIVERSAL IDENTIFIER
LINK ACROSS THE THAMES. WE HVE
SUGGESTIONS AND WOULD LOVE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
DEPARTMENT ON HOW TO PURSUE THE
GOAL OF PROVIDING A MORE
UNIFIED ACCEPTER THERE RECEIVED
IN A DIFFERENT MANNER SIMILAR
TO HOW WE'VE SEEN THAT CANADIAN
BRITISH COLUMBIA GOVERNMENT-
PROVIDES THE DISTANCE THAT A
SINGLE POINT OF ACCESS TO
SERVICES- ALL THREAT THE RED
CARD. CARD PROVIDE WRITTEN BACK
TO THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSES HELP
ID INTEGER ID WHILE MAINTAINING
UNIQUE RECORDS IN EACH
DEPARTMENT- WE REALLY
APPRECIATED THAT THAT HE'S
APPROACH IN WELCOMING THE
COLDER INVOLVEMENT AND
ENGAGEMENT AND WE URGE THEM TO
BUILD ON THE EXPERTISE FROM
THOSE IN TELECOM BALLY TECH-
CREATE IMPACTED THAT- YOU KNOW
IT. PRIVACY PROTECTION AND DATA
PROTECTION THAN MINE IN MARKHAM
FURTHER CONVERSATION THANK. YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE PLEASE. MEXICO ALIGNED SO
PLEASE AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
MAY SHUTTLES I MEAN OF THE
JEWEL'S CATCH ONE. HI SOME COM
DISTRICT- I'M CALLING SUPPORT
OF THE NUMBER NINE. WE ARE HERE
BLACK LGBT. ARE COMING UP ON
OUR FIFTH YEAR ANNIVERSARY NEXT
YEAR- FOR EVERYONE HAVING SEEN
THE DOCUMENTARY ON NETFLIX
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF OUR CLUB
RIGHT IT'S AMAZING DOCUMENT
ABOUT THE INCLUSIVITY OUR OTHER
AMAZING SPACE- WE HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO OPERATE NOW FOR.
FOURTEEN MONTHS- IN THE HARDEST
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE ARE WE
WERE THE FIRST TO CLOSE IN
ORDER TO BE THE LAST OPEN ARE
UNEMPLOYED FOR SIXTY PEOPLE AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
ABLE TO- TO GET THOSE PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK HI IMPROPERLY FOR
ANOTHER SIXTY YEARS- SO THAT'S
WHY I NEED TO POINT OUT- ISSUE
NUMBER FORTY NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE.
WE GOT A LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MA'AM
TERROR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BRITTANY BARZANI I'M
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION COLIN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ITEM. FIFTY TOWARDS-
RECOVERY CAMPAIGN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
MEXICO LINE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SAN BENITO COUNTY ARTS COUNCIL
BASED IN HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA
AND SENATOR CAPITO DISTRICT.
I'M CALLING IN TODAY TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT FOR ITEM FORTY NINE
THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FOR THE RECOVERY OF THE
ART CULTURE AND CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA. MY
ORGANIZATION THIRD OF THE
STATE'S LOCAL PARTNER TO THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IN SAN
BENITO COUNTY AND WE HAVE
WITNESSED THE DIRECT AND
EXPONENTIAL IMPACT THAT STATE
ARTS FUNDING HAS HAD IN MY
COMMUNITY FROM AN POINT ARTISTS
WRITTEN BY BRETT NEIGHBORHOOD
GENERATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HEALTH AND HEALING AND
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES TO STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES OF COLOR WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY AND CONSISTENTLY
UNDERFUNDED AND UNDER RESOURCE.
OVER THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS
ALONE MY ORGANIZATION HAD
BROUGHT IN A HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND IN STATE ARTS FUNDING
THE FAMILY OF COUNTY THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF WHICH
IS REDISTRIBUTED LOCAL ARTISTS
AND ARTS ORGANIZATIONS FOR
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. THIS
FUNDING IS LEVERAGED BY PRIVATE
FUNDING AND EARNED INCOME FOR
AN OVERALL ECONOMIC MULTIPLIER
EFFECT THAT BENEFIT THE BROADER.
LOCAL AND REGIONAL ECONOMY. IN
FACT I THINK STATE LOCAL
PARTNER MULTIPLIED ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL INVESTMENT BY SIXTY
EIGHT TIMES. AND THIS IS JUST
ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL SEVERAL GRANT PROGRAMS.
NOW IS THE TIME TO THINK BOLDLY
AND HARNESS OUR CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES AND SERVICE OF
CALIFORNIA'S RECOVERY. I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE FUNDING
REQUEST. I WISH TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. HANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT PLEASE. NEXT WE GOT A
LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JESSICA LANDER
AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF TERRA KULTURE ALLEN
NONPROFIT EDUCATIONAL ECO
EXPIRING BEATS IN THE ROMANCE.
AND I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR ITEM FORTY NINE THE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR THE RECOVERY OF THE ARTS
CULTURE AND CREATIVE INDUSTRIES
IN CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION
MISSION IN CENTERED AROUND
STRENGTHENING COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE THEIR COLLABORATIVE
I JUST LET COMMUNITY PROJECTS
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
ACCEPTABLE TO THEM. IN A REGION
OF THE CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH
EFFECTS OF THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC
ARTS FUNDING LIKE THAT TO THE
SPECIALLY VITAL TO OUR
ORGANIZATION AND TO OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
ALIGNS DIPPED THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HELLO CAN
CHRISTIANSEN. IT OPERATES A
MENTOR IN LOS ANGELES LOCATED
IN MID CITY CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF- ITEM NUMBER FORTY NINE-
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE MINUTE WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN IST INDEPENDENTLY OWNED
AND IS ONE OF LA'S OLDEST MUSIC
LIVE MUSIC VENUES WE ARE A
MEMBER OF NEW- AND SO IN NORMAL
TIMES WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
OR SO EMPLOYEES- OPERATING A
VENUE IS NEVER EASY. IN IN
NORMAL TIMES AND MOST OF THOSE
VENUE OWNERS HAVE BEEN DOING
ALL KINDS OF HARDSHIPS AND
OVERCOME MANY OBSTACLES IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE DOORS OPEN
OVER THE YEARS BUT NEVER LIKE
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THIS PAST
YEAR WITH THE PANDEMIC IN THE
SHUT DOWN- FUNDS ARE SORELY
NEEDED TO PAY THINGS LIKE
BACKGROUND UTILITIES. MAKE
REPAIRS ALONG DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OF THE SPECIAL
EQUIPMENT PURCHASE INVENTORY
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY BRING BACK
OUR OUR EMPLOYEES- I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN BE STRESSED
ENOUGH THAT THE CONTINUATION OF
A LIVE MUSIC VENUES LIKE US AND
OTHERS. ARE ESSENTIAL TO
SUPPORTING L. PLAYS CULTURAL
SCENE AND NOT JUST ONLY AROUND
THE WORLD AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND SUPPORTING THE THOUSANDS OF
YOUNG ASPIRING ARTISTS- I
STRONGLY URGE THAT CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SUPPORT NIEVE- AND
THEN THAT THESE VENUES ARE
WEIGHING OUT THEIR BUDGET AND.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JOHN CALDWELL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND
LODGING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF ITEM ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY- OUR
HOTELS WANT TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL. YOU WANT TO BRING BACK
EMPLOYEES BUT WE NEED GAS AND-
THIS TOURISM RECOVERY CAMPAIGN
CAN HELP US DO THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT. SIX
ZERO NINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME'S
JEANINE WAS NASTY STALE AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ITEM FORTY
NINE I AM A THEATER ARTIST NINE
MANAGING DIRECTOR OF THE NEW
AMERICAN THEATER BASED IN
CULVER CITY HELLO WE ARE A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
ORGANIZATION CELEBRATING IN
TWENTY TWENTY HOWEVER WE WERE
SHUT DOWN LIKE ALL THE OTHER
PERFORMING ARTS ORGANIZATIONS
DUE TO. THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC I'M
CALLING TODAY TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR THE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR THE
RECOVERY OF THE ARTS CULTURE
AND CREATIVE INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA- I BELIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL HE'S A
COMPETENT STATE AGENCY AND I
HAVE A CONTINENT THAT CAN
HANDLE THE GRANT SPECIALLY S A
DESIGNATION IS OVER THREE YEARS
IF NOT ALL AT ONCE. OUR COMPANY
IS A CREATIVE ARTIST HELM PETER
COMPANY WE SEEK TO INSPIRE
EDUCATE AND NURTURE ARTISTS IN
OUR COMMUNITY TOWARD THE
FOXHOLE IN HUMANE WORLD VIEWS
TO THE ART OF STORYTELLING WE
HELP YOUNG THEATER ARTISTS BUT
YOUR VOICE IS CALLED SOCIAL
CONSCIOUSNESS THE PAIR FOR A
LASTING CAREER WE SUPPORT NEW
AND ESTABLISHED PLAYWRIGHTS WE
INCUBATE NEW PLACE. ALL OF
THIS- WAS SHUT DOWN LAST YEAR
AND WE ARE ASKING FOR YOUR HELP
THROUGH SUPPORTING THIS. ONE
BILLION DOLLAR RECOVERY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. ZERO ONE THIRTY FOUR
SHE'S AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
DIMITRI AT THIS REPRESENT THE
GREEK THEATRE BERKELEY EAST BAY
VENUE COALITION IN THE
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ITEM NUMBER FORTY
NINE THE PROPOSED ONE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
AREN'T ANY INDEPENDENT BENNY
GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN. THAT WILL
HELP KEEP OUR INDEPENDENT
PERFORMANCE SPACES IN
CALIFORNIA LIVE AS WE COME OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC WE CAN CONTINUE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. LIVE MUSIC VENUES
PERFORMANCE SPACES AND
PROMOTERS ARE DRIVERS FOR A
LOCAL ECONOMIES. FOR EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT ON A TICKET. WELL
THE DEFENDANT'S ROUNDING
DIFFERENCES. TRANSPIRES
TRANSPORTATION AND LODGING. OUR
INDUSTRY WILL BE CRUCIAL FIRST
STATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY. FOR
EVERY PANDEMIC WE'RE SORRY
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE WILL BE
UNABLE TO WE'VE BEEN UNABLE TO
OPERATE YOUR REVENUE FOR
FOURTEEN MONTHS AND OUR
OPERATING COSTS WILL INCREASE
TO REOPEN WITH NEW SAFETY
PROTOCOLS. PLEASE HELP LIVE
ENTERTAINMENT VENUES REOPEN
SAFELY SO WE CAN QUICKLY
REBOUND TO A BUSTLING ECONOMY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE.
THANKS TO THE LINE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS HEATHER
MARTIN AND I'M THE OWNER OF
BECAUSE THE NIGHT AND CO
FOUNDER OF B. LA IV E. WHICH IS
THE ONLY CHAPTER OF NEVA-
MINIMAL TIME MEMBER OF NEVA
CALIFORNIA IN COVER LIKE LOCKED
INTO IT- AND LA COUNTY'S
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES REPRESENT A
TOTAL ECONOMIC IMPACT OF TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION. AND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR. THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT TOTAL JOBS-
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID THEY
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSED INDEPENDENT BANK
NEEDS GRANT PROGRAM TO KEEP OUR
INDEPENDENT AGES IN CALIFORNIA
LIVE. AS PART A OF ITEM NUMBER
FORTY NINE- WE ALSO REPRESENT A
RICH AND DIVERSE CULTURE- THAT
MAKES UP THE COLORFUL NETWORK
OF CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
VENUES WERE COMMITTED TO
CURATING AN INCLUSIVE AND
EQUITABLE ENVIRONMENT. THAT
SERVICE- THE WHOLE COMMUNITY OF
MEMBERS- WE KNOW THAT DIVERSITY
IS OUR STRENGTH AND MORE
MOTIVATED BY THE VALUES AND
BELIEFS THAT THERE'S ROOM AT
THE TABLE- SO- AGAIN I SUPPORT.
ITEM FORTY NINE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. I ACTUALLY
GOT A LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS GABRIEL DR
AN ERROR PRESENT AUGUST HALL IN
SAN FRANCISCO A MEMBER OF ANY-
NEED TO CALIFORNIA AND SAN
FRANCISCO VENUE COALITION I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
ITEM FORTY NINE TO HELP THE
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT VENUES. INDEPENDENT
MENUS ARE ANCHOR BUSINESSES
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL VITALITY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES THE LIVE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY DIRECTLY
IMPACTS THE ECONOMIC HEALTH OF
RESTAURANTS BARS RETAIL AND
TOURISM SPIN BACK WE HAVE IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS HAS BEEN
ILLUSTRATED BY THE EMPTY
STREETS AND VACANT STOREFRONTS
THAT HAVE BEEN. UNPOPULATED
SINCE OUR ONGOING CLOSURE IN
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY. WELL THE
POSSIBILITY AND VIABILITY OF
VENUES REOPENING- INCHES CLOSER
TO REALITY. HOPEFULLY FOR THE
FALL OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
IT WILL TAKE. YEARS FOR THE
LIVE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY-
OVERCOME THE MOUNTAINS OF DEBT
WE RECRUIT. SUPPORTING TARGETED
GRANTS ARE INDEPENDENT VENUES
WILL PREVENT FURTHER PERMANENT
CLOSURE OF THESE BUSINESSES
BRING THOUSANDS OF JOBS BACK TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND EMPOWER OUR
INDUSTRY TO HELP STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY AND CULTURE COVERAGE OF
OUR ENTIRE STATE IN THE WAKE OF
THE PENDING. PLEASE SUPPORT
ITEM. FORTY NINE THANK YOU ARE
YOU MY DAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSHUA ARE THE
MONTHS AND I AM A COMPANY
MEMBER. TEACHING ARTIST AND THE
DEVELOPMENT MANAGER WITH THE
ACTORS GANG GET A COMPANY IN
CULVER CITY CALIFORNIA AND AT
THE GRAND KEY OF THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL AND A PROUD MEMBER
OF DISTRICT THIRTY I'M CALLING
TODAY TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT.
FOR THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FOR THE RECOVERY OF THE
ART CULTURE AND CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
JOINING THE COMPANY AND THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL AND HELP SUPPORT
OUR FREE SHAKESPEARE IN THE
PARK. THIS PROVIDES FREE
SHAKESPEARE ADAPTATION. FOR
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS INCLUDING DISTRICT
THIRTY RESIDENTS. WITH THAT 65%
BEING UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN. CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS
HAS ALSO BEEN KEY TO THE GROWTH
OF THE ACTORS GANG PRISON
PROJECT AND THE ACTING
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT- WHICH
SUPPORT. AND PROVIDE SUPPORT.
TO LOW COST AND FREE THEATER
ARTS EDUCATION PROGRAMMING TO
CHILDREN INCLUDING TITLE ONE
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS ON THE
FRINGES OF THE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WITH- GRANTS AND THE ARTS IN
SCHOOL ARE SCHOOL ARE AND YOU.
EXPOSURE PROGRAM AND THE U. R.
ACTION- THAT PRISON PROJECT IS
A- TO WORK IN THE- OF THE
SPECIES TRANSFER. ARTS PRO
WHICH IS TO THANK. PROGRAM AND
IT HAS ALLOWED US TO X. OUR- TO
FIFTEEN YARDS AND THIRTEEN. IN
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO ARE- DURING
T. OF THE RAIN TO THE ARTS
PROGRAM AND THE JUMPSTART'S
PROGRAM WHICH- WHICH- WE'RE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FREE
PROGRAMMING INSIDE CALIFORNIA
ARTS. CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS
TO BE INTERESTED LADIES AND
JUVENILE DETENTION CAMPS- FOR
MEN AND WOMEN AND CHILDREN
IMPACTED BY THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AS A TEACHING ARTIST I CAN SEE
I AM- FIRSTHAND INSIGHT SEEING
WHAT- THE ARTISTS ARE DOING FOR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND. FOR THOSE
IMPACTED- AND ABBAS SYSTEM AND
IT IS- THAT WE CAN I CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH HOW IMPORTANT DETAILS ON
ARTS COUNCIL HAS BEEN TO- BY
SWITCHING THOSE THOSE
POPULATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT PLEASE. AND
ACTUALLY GO TO ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MARTHA JENSEN I AMTHE BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
THEATRICAL PRODUCERS LEAGUE OF
LOS ANGELES. THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR SMALL THEATERS
IN LA COUNTY I'M CALLING TO
SPEAK ON ITEM FORTY NINE-
BELIEVES STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE-
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FOR THE RECOVERY OF THE ARTS
CULTURE AND CREATIVE INDUSTRIES
IN CALIFORNIA. PARTICULARLY
WOULD LIKE TO DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO AS THE EIGHT OH
FIVE AUTHORED BY SENATORS RUBIO
AND ALAN CALLING FOR THE
CREATION OF A NON PROFIT HE
MASTER- THAT MINISTERED TO THE-
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF AN EQUITABLE.
HEY WORLD SUBSIDY FUND WE
BELIEVE THE ARTS COUNCIL IS-
HIGHLY COMPETENT STATE AGENCY
CERTAINLY CAPABLE OF
ADMINISTERING THIS PROGRAM. IF
I WAS PART OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PART OF THIS
FUNDING ALONGSIDE SP. SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. OVERALL THE JUST
HEY WERE. SUBSIDY IS ESSENTIAL
TO ENSURE PAY EQUITY GOING
FORWARD TO PUT OUR ARTIST BACK
TO WORK AFTER FOURTEEN MONTHS
OF UNEMPLOYMENT AND TO AVOID A
PERMANENT SHUT DOWN OF
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL PERFORMING
ARTS. ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NOT A
MODERATOR- MARTIN LEAVE IT TO
MR MODERATOR COULD YOU TELL US
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE STILL IN
QUEUE. YES AT THE MOMENT WE
HAVE TWO MORE IN Q. VERY GOOD.
OKAY AND WE GO TO ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN. HI I'M- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
MOMENT CRYING I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE U. S. FEDERATION
OF WORKER COOPERATIVES NATIONAL
GRASSROOTS MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION FOR WORK ON
BUSINESSES BASED IN OAKLAND-
I'M I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT- OR ISSUE FIFTY ONE
ENTITIES AGENDA THAT WILL GROW
CONVERSIONS OF MY BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA TO WORKER OWNERSHIP
AND- PRESERVATION LAYOFF
AVERSION AND WEALTH BUILDING
STRATEGY- WE REPRESENT MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE BUSINESSES
SEVENTY NINE BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
OWNED AND GOVERNED BY THEIR
WORKERS. INCLUDING SOME OF OUR
OLDEST COOPERATIVES IN THE
COUNTRY SUCH AS REMEMBER STREAM
TEMPERATURES GO INTO OUR
COLLECTIVE AND BERKELEY- AND
COOPERATIVES ALL ACROSS THE
STATE- WE WANT TO BUILD UPON
THE SUCCESSES THAT WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN FOR DECADES AND IN
CALIFORNIA- ESPECIALLY NOW IN
THE WAKE OF KOBE NINETEEN WE
NEED THE COURT TO SUPPORT
STRUGGLING SMALL BUSINESSES BY
GIVING THEM OPTIONS THIS
PROPOSAL- TO DEDICATE STATEWIDE
OUTREACH AND EDUCATION- AS WELL
AS CAPITAL T. AGENCY THAT
EDUCATION THROUGH ARE REALLY
INTEGRAL TO BUILDING A MORE
INCLUSIVE RESILIENT ECONOMY. IF
THEY TO SUPPORT ISSUE FIFTY ONE
AND THE EXPANSION OF THE WORKER
CAUGHT MODEL IT'S BEEN A GOOD
WORKERS AND BUSINESSES ACROSS
ALL SECTORS OF OUR ECONOMY AND
CAN BE A BUSINESS MEETING
SOLUTION FOR CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE. THE NEXT TO
THE LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
RAMBLING HEIDI LOPEZ AND I
REPRESENT THE REDWOOD BAR WHILE
ALSO BECAUSE WE CANNOT OF
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES I STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED INDEPENDENT VENUES
GRANT PROGRAM. OR INDEPENDENT
DO THE CALIFORNIA LOTTERY YOU
COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC
SWEEPING. ACROSS STATE LIVE
MUSIC VENUES ARE ECONOMIC
DRIVERS FOR THE NEIGHBORHOODS
WE OPERATE I EVERY DOLLAR
SPENT ON EACH TICKET TWELVE
DOLLARS IS GENERATED IN OUR
SURROUNDING ECONOMY. OUR
INDUSTRY WILL BE CRUCIAL TO OUR
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
DURING A PANDEMIC WE HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO OPERATE ZERO REVENUE
FOR FOURTEEN MONTHS APART.
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT THE RE
OPENING OF OUR INDUSTRY. JUST.
GIVE YOU A LOCAL ECONOMY
SLUGGISH THING. WHAT WE OPEN
WITH YOU STATEMENT IN PLACE. TO
REACH. OUT LATER TODAY WE OPEN
SAFELY SHOULD BE CAN RESUME
CONTROL FORTY PLUS ON. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE
THERE ANY FURTHER OUR PHONES IN
THE QUEUE. IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE TWO MORE THAT HAVE QUEUED
UP VERY GOOD TO MARK OKAY. OKAY
HE WILL GO TO ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ANTHONY LANE AND I REPRESENT
THE FOX THEATER IN POMONA
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
NEVADA CALIFORNIA PERSONALLY
NEXT- I'M IN CENTER COLORADO'S
DISTRICT. AND- I DON'T WANNA BE
REPETITIONS ON MANY OTHER
THINGS IT IS IT IS I'M IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM FORTY NINE IT
IS SO IMPORTANT THAT WE OPEN UP
OUR STAGES AGAIN FOR MANY
REASONS ONE I GET SOME OF OUR
MUSICIANS BACK TO WORK AND OUR
STAFF BACK TO WORK. AND NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE CONCERTS IN
KEEPING IT AT THE MOVIES AT OUR
VENUE WE ALSO ARE A STRONG
ANCHOR IN OUR DOWNTOWN AND WE
SUPPORT MANY OF THE LIBRARIES
AND SCHOOLS AND WE GIVE OUR
CHILDREN THE STAGE TO PERFORM
ON SO WITH THAT BEING SAID I
HOPE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I'VE NEVER HAD TO ASK FOR ANY
HELP OR ASSISTANCE PRIOR TO
THIS PANDEMIC BUT TODAY I
HUMBLY ASK FOR MYSELF AT ALL OR
OTHERS. IN SUPPORT OF- SUPPORT
FOR VENUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR LANE IT'S GOOD TO HEAR YOUR
VOICE AGAIN AND I APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING IN TODAY. NEXT
PLEASE. THERE WE GO TO ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU- THIS REGARD ISSUE
FORTY NINE THE INDEPENDENT
THING IS GRANT PROGRAM. MY NAME
IS CRYSTAL CLEAR AND I'M ON THE
BOARD DIRECTORS AND ASK NOT
MUSIC AND DANCE COMMUNITY
CENTER IN BERKELEY AND WE'RE A
MEMBER OF NEVA CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR
ALMOST FIFTY YEARS AND WE'VE
BEEN A NONPROFIT MOST OF THAT
TIME. AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC WE'VE BEEN COMPLETELY
SHUT DOWN SINCE LAST MARCH.
GIVEN OUR BUSINESS MODEL WHICH
IS PROVIDING AN INCLUSIVE.
CROSS CULTURALLY INDOOR SPACE
FOR LIVE MUSIC AND SOCIAL
DANCING OUR PATHWAY TO FULLY RE
OPENING IT IT'S GOING TO BE A
LONG AND EXPENSIVE ONE. WE ARE
MENTALLY COMMITTED TO OPERATE
AGAIN WE WILL NEED TO RE HIRE
STAFF FANS AND REBUILD OUR
AUDIENCE. LIKE MANY OF THE
VENUES ARE PART OF ME BUT WE'VE
NEVER HAD TO ASK FOR HELP OR
ASSISTANCE BEFORE. BUT GIVEN
THE UNCERTAINTIES YOU'RE FACING
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE WE
ARE HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT POST INDEPENDENT. BANKS
GRANTS PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU MUCH. THANK PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE NO OTHER CONFERENCE
COMMENTERS IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. YOU CAN- THERE WERE-
HAVING COMPLETED ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION OF OUR OF OUR
HEARING HOW MANY CHECK BACK
WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR ISSUES THAT WENT
THEY WON A RACE AT THIS TIME.
SENATOR KAMMERER AND I JUST
WANT TO APPLAUD ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE ARTS COMMUNITY
WHO CALLED IN TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF ISSUE FORTY NINE- AND IT IS
NOT SPECIFICALLY FOLKS FROM THE
THIRTIETH ALTHOUGH I HEARD YOU-
BUT IT IS CRYSTAL CLEAR TO ME
THAT THE ARTS ARE AN INTEGRAL
PART OF ANY KINDOF COMMUNITY
OR SOCIETY- THEY ARE THE
DRIVERS OF SO MANY BUSINESSES-
AND OFTEN ARE LEADING THE WAY
IN TERMS OF HOW WE HEAL AND
COMMUNICATE AND TRANSLATE- AND
SO GLAD TO SEE THIS ON- THE-
AGENDA TODAY AND REALLY
GRATEFUL TO HEAR FROM ALL OF
THEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I ABSOLUTELY AGREE SENATOR
NELSON NO COMMENTS- YEAH I WANT
A SECOND THAT- I. MY CONCERN IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT GETS DEEP
ENOUGH INTO THE COMMUNITY SO
THAT- TO THE COMMUNITY THAT
RARELY GET ARTS MONEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE COMPETITIVE
AND TO GET RESOURCES IS OFF BUT
I DO THINK ALL OF THE TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY- ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE ARE YOU CONVICTED
SAID OUR WEBSITE TO MAKE SURE
TO RECORD AT YOUR COMMENTS YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS SO
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE BACK ON A NUMBER OF
THESE ITEMS TODAY- AND SO MORE
ON THAT IN THE FUTURE THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T TAKE THEM UP
TODAY'S DOES NOT MEAN THAT
THEY'RE NOT IMPORTANT TO US. IT
JUST MEANS THAT WE NEED MORE
DATA AND MORE INFORMATION- AND
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
HEARD THEM SO WE USUALLY BRING
THEM BACK AND- AND TAKE ACTION
ON THE SECOND TIME SO- AND THEY
WERE GOING TO MOVE ON. TO A
VOTE ON THE ISSUES. I'D LIKE TO
TAKE UP ISSUE. ISSUES NUMBER
FOUR. NUMBER EIGHT. NUMBER TEN
NUMBER NINETEEN. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. 242-728-2930. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY NINE FORTY
FORTY ONE AND FORTY TWO. SO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THOSE
ITEMS. THE MOTION IS MADE BY
SENATOR CAMPBELL ORDER. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BARBERO HI ON
LONGER I WILL SEND. VERY GOOD
SO THAT- THAT MOTION PASSES
THREE ICE SNOW ZERO. SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO THE
REMAINING ITEMS WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO.
867-911-1213. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX THIRTY THIRTY TWO
THIRTY THREE THIRTY FOUR THIRTY
FIVE THIRTY SIX ANDTHIRTY
SEVEN IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA FOR THESE IEMS-
MOVED AGAIN A MOTION BY SENATOR
CAMEL AUGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE
STATE THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BARBERO
FIVE FUN LONGER I WILL SEND.
THAT MOTION PASSES ALL RIGHTS
TO KNOW. ZERO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY FORTY THREE
WHICH IS THE AUGMENTATION AND
CONTINUATION OF RESOURCES FOR
THE LICENSED PHYSICIAN AND
DENNIS FROM THE MEXICO PILOT
PROJECT THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION. SO
MOVED. THE MOTION IS BEEN MADE
BY SENATOR KEN LONGER. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF AERO HI I'M
LONGER I NIELSEN. THE VOTE IS
TWO IN FAVOR ZERO AGAINST THAT
MOTION PASSES ISSUE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR WHICH IS THE C. A.
DOT GOV RESOURCES THE MOTION IS
TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION- MOVED. BOTH BY
MOTION AGAIN IS BY SENATOR CAN
LONGER- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
AERO I AM LAGER I WILL SEND.
THE MOTION PASSES TO RISE ONE
NO. THE NEXT ITEM IS ISSUE
NUMBER FORTY SIX WHICH IS THE
CONSOLIDATED HEADQUARTERS
COMPLEX IN THE MOTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION
MOVED MOTION IS MADE BY SENATOR
COME LONGER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF AERO HI. I'M LAGER HI
YELTSIN. MOTION PASSES THREE
EYES. NOSE ZERO AND FINALLY
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY TWO WHICH IS
THE ENTERPRISE DATED TO REVENUE
PROJECT PHASE TWO THE MOTION IS
TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. AGAIN MOVED BY
SENATOR COME LONGER- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL HAVE AERO I FOUND
I FEEL FOR THEM. THE MOTION
PASSES TO RISE ONE NO. THAT'S
IT THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WE HAVEN'T CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU.